ravi de vous retrouver pour c'est 33 du
tata steel alors première chose avant de
voir le programme ci déjà quelques uns
d'entre vous sont dans le tchat je veux
bien un petit retour sur le son si tout
est ok
et on pourra se lancer
en attendant du coup le point de la
première ronde je souffre qu'est ce que
tu en penses des différentes parties au
genre de galles elle affiche qui allèche
le plus si j'ose dire
alors après
on voit qu'on a le plusieurs duels
fratricides et on peut dire ça qu'on m'a
carrément déjà
[Musique]
mis les doigts difficulté champions il a
fait deux grosses parties est très
longue il
peut souffrir de très gros party mais il
n'a pas réussi à
gagner c'est parti malheureusement il
avait encore en d'agir
double visite c'est intéressant
je vais
moi aussi j'ai vu qu'il avait déclaré l
après la ronde la balle première ronde
je crois mamede rock c'était un type à
envoyer en l'air il avait sacrifié pris
beaucoup de risques mais il était
heureux de retrouver son style de se
lâcher quitte à perdre mais du coup je
pense que ça devrait une partie sans
participer aux canadiens
un essai alberico ok monsieur
[Musique]
changer de thème que je t'annonce la
première news de la journée et si pink
aucun irakienne je propose qu'on aura
moins de 2 à
huile mort qu'elle ait eu contre la
maigreur
compliqué ils n'avaient leur embargo
mais il a fait nul seront
donc ne sais pas j'ai du mal à avoir un
gros match
mais
on a vu que carrier khemiri la finul
sans jouer quasiment contredit bof
malgré la polémique récente alors qu'il
avait les blancs donc je pense qu'avec
les noirs ça très heureux de faire nul
et puis carakan il a gardé ses prépas
pour le tour des candidats toute façon
donc la magie là pour s'entraîner mais
n'en a pas il n'a rien montré quoi
les plus importants qu'ils à paris mort
remarque dans le chat que tu t'es rasé
je pense que des teams ans à éclipse
tout le reste alors qu'aujourd'hui de
dbm là le mandat avec le grand fin du
roman il fallait que je sois rasé venu
comme ça on est déserte il pour quelque
chose
à priori oui
c'est nagui mamediarov ça je trouve ça
va être sympa parce que mal d'erreurs il
était hyper créatif vous qui depuis hier
il a sorti un chèque est un peu gros
besq de derrière les fagots là et dire
il a perdu contre 15,7 donc il va
vouloir se refaire avec beaucoup
devraient avoir de réponse balconnet de
gilan père avant lui tend à faire
peut-être tennisman est venu mais il ya
des petites cités il va là où il ya des
idées et puis tous un peu mais il est
donc intéressant de voir ce que ça
donne bien aussi c'est tout un carter
c'est l'affichage on note qu'un bon
ouais parce que franchement bravo da
hockey au delà la carte - 11 juillet
mais jouer pour score contre le cancer
il a déjà paramètres entrent en vigueur
sous quinzaine deux joueurs qui ont tous
le droit qui fait et va entreprendre par
erreur ou malus pleinement de rap il
déborde vite et a conduit les
changements dans le monde arabe de bill
salvin a été le plaisir de perdre un
maximum quand même mais il a fait il a
fait à bichancourt nîmes en anglais et
en rapide vers doit être nuls à la
victoire faut dire de gagner et ils
aiment de portland tour s'ils gagnent la
partie qui paient normalement emma il
aurait fait barrage contre
contre un dépôt du compte pour que les
bo aura fermé même de dérapages qui voit
notamment des vêtements avant la finale
en planifiant
sap aurait envie de le confirmer il y
longtemps et aurait selon un joueur qui
au kiki
qui dure encore prier bon bah on
tintaine
peut-être lui reims passé mais
pour moi qu'ils sont partis sur une
horrible open your eyes à revenir au
fini juste les appariements ne reste
deux autres partis ou narbonne fort est
un jeune homme d'à la cemac un petit bug
beaucoup n'aura pas le plaisir de voir
ton petit chouchou indien en images on
va voir sa position
une belle affiche en plus entre les
pattes ces deux jeunes et maintenant
énormément et en reste avec des blancs
blancs vraiment un truc genre en plus au
fromage et du coup les noms mais je
pense avoir enrôlé pour jeunes
encadrants et près de
vingt films en europe que lui ça peut
jouer sans résultat en france
vous allez voir à l'action enfin on a eu
en
chalosse mais en plus en osant courbet
est offert dans la grande île ce rapport
est un beau ça peut être une partie
intéressante ips grands débuts où il a
les deux joueurs ont un style assez
fantasque rapport il est capable de
gagner et de couleurs donc donc on verra
ce que ça donne
je vous propose de commencer par
s'intéresser directement à un doux da
contre contre cadalen
alors les deux joueurs sont debout du
coup c'est marrant voilà c'est typique
ça fait penser à la fin du monde
puisqu'il ya personnes à table et on a
la même ouverture une
lopez donc on reste dans le thème on ne
change pas une équipe qui gagne pour un
combat que nadal
dans les davidoff
beauté intérieure
et
c'est l'ouverture la plus chère au monde
je pense un peu de chances de se tromper
en disant ça
va être vraiment de l'archi terrorisme
ou classe a va débiter beaucoup de cours
à voir lequel des deux a une idée en
premier
et sur petit rock on sait
à 4 donc qui caractérise ce qui est une
des possibilités de jouer un anti
marshall ce qui est hyper à la mode le
combier marshall c'est quand les noirs
veulent sacrifier à qui on parle des 5
vous êtes déjà pu voir un certain nombre
de fois pour l'activité s'amène très
souvent raté nul c'est archi théorique
ça peut avoir entre un des nuls basse en
juin c'est le coût par soi même
donc ce cas la mode pour chercher des
petits avantages que je descende si
marshall ou comme à 4
et tour bay beach où tu vas me dire si
je me trouve mais c'était déjà joué en
championnat du monde du coup
après sa blessure la partie non nous
avons à plusieurs
il est uni béquille qui est assez
récurrent en position délicate pour un
effort visible
et on se battra ou ou surtout met à
pleurer avec la c3 les daaf
alors cette fois qu'on a des bons
combats pros crime est de savoir
où en est on va lentement va intervenir
s'asseoir à les gens sont assis
et
voir ce que
tout est à choisir je prends h 30 ok
donc il permet d avoir des 5 contre ses
parents le match alors le hollow annonce
est publiée
mais
paris
nous ont convié sa soeur c'est sûr mais
désiste croient savoir
les coûts assez assez classique sans
oublier dh 3 à un coût bien sûr
prophylactique c'est de contrôler la
quasi cap pour éviter de se faire couper
ici puisque d'ici là ont gelé comme
cette position pour les bourses est
souvent de pousser ses pions des quatre
se bat pour le sortent ici à le canal le
faut car yannick lecavalier pourrait
être embêté puisque ce cavalier
important dans la défense deux des
quatre ans les gens ont continué de
débiter leur trépas donc la carène kgb 4
atenco
leur balade le portrait intéressant et
l'idée d'échanger mais les pions mais il
est plus noire et ses deux princesses a
l'air d'être un coin c'est rare je
profite de chaque instant
pour sur la base tu es comme j'ai que
quatre parties ce qui me paraît très peu
puisque l'impression que la position est
quand même connu
aucun n'est pas surpris les joutes
détroit et est ce que maxime il n'a pas
joué de les positions comme ça aussi
puisqu'il joue beaucoup d'espagnols
pas si wayne
faught
m'aimait pas soin de sa structure tu es
vraiment symétrique à la contrainte
est pas une partie de championnat du
monde pourtant je me plaisais à regarder
je me souviens que où les tables comme
ça a indiqué télé poubelle disparaissent
ouais mais tu peux même la fameuse en
partie au dépôt il s'est fait enfermer
son faux là où il a raté en ckd pour
prendre davantage soin c'était pas ça
j'ai l'impression que ça ressemble mais
j'ai pas certain les saluts ruth merci
merci à toi
en tout cas j'ai une impression de déjà
vu
on va voir le à quel moment y en a qui
se met à réfléchir vraiment on en
profitera peut-être pour changer
d'échiquier
un trophée saga professeur h3h trois des
six essais 3 maintenant
ce qui me semblait b4
et la carte à jouer même deux à cette
position qui est légal duda a aussi jeu
qui doit bien connaître la position
au p4 c'est normal c'est la partie
qui a vu un dépôt graciet cloche plein
tout le monde c'est là qu'elle est du
coup partie basse à la partie où je
prends la quarantaine a sonné par un
dc10 à quinssaines est devenu champion
du non on gagne et que les noirs c'est
parce que la patrouille c'est la partie
non
mais c'est la partie ou en fait l'un des
jeunes aurait pu en dépôt
qui me semblait mais on ne
s'était pas il se défonce est trop
ancien
alors oui ça de
3,2
les quinze ans avait joué quoi du coup
ici à hilla but en position dangereuse
ici parce que
je me suis d'abord il avait dû faire un
dame est vite il trouvait plus de coups
c'était assez difficile et c'est là
qu'un dépôt a même manqué clairement de
précision et d'objets mais
jamais je vais des soins que maintenant
des simples
qui avait eu des 5 ans du recours qu'ils
disent on va essayer de voir déjà
stéphane pourquoi pourquoi les blancs ne
peuvent pas gagner le tour un second
mandat ça vous va couvrir la colonie et
donc potentiellement peut-être se dire
y'a un film qui tombe dans le site
comprend pourquoi donc crise
qu'à l'allier trop juste qu'est ce qui
se passe sur canale 5
pourquoi c'est pas bon france le premier
à comprendre d après ce que tu vois on a
même en rhône alpes en suisse c'est une
sorte de deux marshals
devant le marchal oreillette ou
finalement
deux pièces ouais mais t'as pas trop la
tacc que tu as d'habiter dans le
marshall où tu arrives à mener des
pièces vitales a time et après après
n'était
hélas exactement il ya des menaces en
fait les fous noirs sont sont très
intéressants cette position et les
blancs ont du mal à vraiment développer
leurs pièces comme pour ses 3 fr
l'adapt devant le foot donc un petit peu
lié à des problèmes pratiques et
normalement c'est ce qui va permettre
aux noix
dc2 sûrement récupérer leurs pions le
voir comme elle même des cas ou à
montréal qc ca
il ya même des canadiens français 3 sur
ce que l'on va me dresser une découverte
il
ya plein de problèmes en fait en plus
des tactiques et qu'ils vont voir et si
jamais les blu dessine l'aide décidée
par nombre essayé de simplifier la
position ici la paire de faux je pense
quand même qu'on penserait assez
largement ses pions en plus que ça reste
un pur il ya un retard de même
maintenant les lignes sont ouvertes donc
ici à défaut ils vont être extrêmement
extrêmement habile dans ce genre de
position donc
c'est quelque chose qui ne va pas être
d'abord intéressant du taux d'alice et
de gagner espérons que je relate le
chien
lors de vos déchets l'allusion
gratifiante
et donc plus haut plus on est fort en
europe en confiance et nous at elle
lancé
les vibrations
will
mais du coup car ça doit changer aussi
il a joué à chis
coûterait anti fonctionne qu'à ce g5
elle est toujours un peu en détente le
pion et possède toujours une cible aux
échecs donc il ya le fouille à leucan
alliés plutôt ici dans cette position
qui peut venir parfois lorsque ces 42
avant de répéter la partie de leur temps
[Musique]
en ligne on
contrôle ou la créatrice a les mains
c'est un type qui est menée qualifie qui
va nous brut et ou après ces
championnats du monde nous glisse alors
bon c'est pareil chez liszt et voilà
duda reaganien la suite il y avait eu
ce match il y avait grève et 2,12 à
l'aiguillé avec les n'aura donc c'est ça
en fait il y avait eu assez marrant
hallyday ce qui avait eu de
réactions l'expérience et le gavage
essonne qui est ok mais là et puis ça
continue à placer sa danse grâce elle
répète la partie 2 da contre 12 heures
il avait connu des preuves contre eux
nés un peu contre des bots il doit
s'attendre à ce que tout allait bien sûr
mener des contres ce qu'il a joué contre
dépôt du coup changé le premier c'est
peut-être pas une mauvaise idée et duda
il joue un coup pas très naturel sort
sous faulx sur trois un coût qui peut
pas être mauvais à priori
là en fait la cellule ans qui la gardait
en plus de parts et d'autres il
est donc normal aussi que le jugement
serait pas mal non donc vous il ya un
geste mayotte le passé colonial et
modulaire donc je pense qu'on n'est pas
la partie après roque aras la sni et du
coup ils peuvent cibler mais le problème
pour une atteinte à une quarantaine
c'est que il est archi préparé il a
énormément bossé pour le match tout que
même si il se produirait pas il peut
déjà être contre préparer dessus mais il
n'a jamais été jouée donc bon on va voir
comment ça évoluera peut-être un petit
peu à voir les autres échiquiers ouais
allez un petit tour sur sur double
visite alors qu'est-ce qui nous a
proposé on va recommencer depuis le
début bof cannes et blanc on a encore du
jeu 4
bon on a encore du classique la cepal
espagnol c'est
une italienne piano kahnisme on a
l'habitude dossier c'est le très haut
niveau avec ses 3 2 toujours un peu
comme au golf c'est un jeu de jouer des
cats au centre
en tout cas c'est en développant une
pièce ultra ça qu'on apprend à contrôler
des buts mais qui est à la mode chez
l'hébergeur du monde
un petit clos à j-6 donc du coup tout de
suite ce qui pose la question au fond le
fort recul et dans ce genre de pollution
ce qui est un talent c'est ce qu'a
demandé la gestion qui va partir ou pas
sachant qu et noir ont pour l'instant
parrot qui est donc qu'ils peuvent
encore plus se le permettre
ici il a commencé par jouer à 5
alors qu'elle dit de maastricht stéphane
je te laisse nous expliquer ça
ça me lie désormais chez mega
man et surtout en fait qui permet aussi
de garder le coup en 1 16 il ya beaucoup
de deux fois où elle est dans mon jeu
même des quatre
parler
donc bokassa empêche les grands espaces
et ça promet du syndicat fo en direct -
c'est un petit moment
interroge
complètement géant attali un trou d'eau
alors c'est dit et redouble donc il nous
a sorti sa petite botte secrète la
lecavalier d'habitude il va plutôt en d2
puisque dans ces schémas on est bien
ramené nos cavaliers via intrants au g3
ou vise plutôt les cases des besoins des
cinq c'est vraiment très très typique de
cette ouverture et olivier dubois qui
fait rien comme tout le monde il a
décidé d'amener son cavalier plutôt sur
le côté on en a trois alors il invite
les noirs potentiellement a le mot
rocher
bon après ça quoi considérer je ne pense
pas que les individus prennent le canal
viennent ici parce qu'il abandonnerait
comme son beau fou pour essayer d'un
petit peu abîmés la structure adverse
mais ça ouvre quand même nicolas donc
plus c'est un jeu très dynamique au
blanc je pense qu'en pratique
et du double fait ce monde car celle du
chemin de mort mais
non mais
dix décès se trouve le camélia droit de
garcia n'diaye seydoux bref qu'il avait
trouvé ça c'est tous les sites et
blogueurs et la
wii est
donc clairement l'idée je pense a été
révélée après la
rencontre
[Musique]
paraît un peu superficielle
à prêter qu'il veut le père d'élise et
le et des gars qui avaient laissé
d'intérêt de 3 ans et porté les gens
vivent et non du passé c'est intéressant
je fais deux par principe je ne mangeais
pas trop en a trois
vous
allez rssi de la vente pour le real
tissot
à nouveau ce trio garde qu'on vous
invite à suivre qui bat estime beaucoup
apprécié la actif réactif il est très
sympa donc n'hésitez pas à les voir sa
chaîne au passage on peut les voir la
chaîne et la faire un petit show il est
très sympa
et on va laisser visiter tranquillement
à cette position va qui tant qu'alan
gross prise de tête ici douba fils
balade tranquille et on va peut-être pas
assez sûrement un petit 15 h en pleurs
de voir ce que ce que fabi voilà on a un
gars là j'ai l'impression
on l'a vérifié reprenons depuis le début
mais alors donc fabi a les blancs ici
elle doit commencer à marquer des points
est champion lui a certainement essayer
de jouer
plus tôt pour l'annuler reflétant solide
après +1 père est contrée mais 3 qu'il a
battu par contre quand notre karma danon
un championnat des états samedi quelque
chose mais peut-être que je fabule s'est
bloqué leur
sanglante qui avait été sacré champion
des états unis à la salle est censé
royal trois autres de 300 choses comme
ça
quand même pas facile de la concurrence
alors qu'on est encore je pense à
quelque chose d'hyper théorique dont
quoi comme je vous l'annonçais c'est un
berlin qui se profile
avec un des changes des dab donc ce
n'est pas réaliste et vus revus au top
niveau et c'est un cas ce que souhaite
mais elle d2 la première est née
la défense me répète à la place de jean
claude
besse puy l'avenir oui bien sûr la
lettre est essentiel
de l très mais bon au canada quand même
des fois des idées hyper profonde donc
après ce qui les prennent en place is it
ok là semble lancée
voilà son tracé des
salaires mais ok
après ça c'est une partie est et chacun
a ses idées alors la double ambition
espace alors en arrêt des roquettes grad
au final
ces gamins c'est assez grisant la part
de vous ce qui est intéressant dans le
berlin c'est que on a une position
asymétriques pour le côté nature de
déséquilibre oui on y gagne et emma
times il ya un déséquilibre en terme de
force etc en présence donc ce que tu
peux nous expliquer un peu et différents
se moquer de moi par exemple ils ont la
paire de faux mais ils ont des pions en
double est donc quels sont les atouts
des blancs et les atouts des noirs ici
là pour toi baldé blanc en fait d'un gps
à ce
jeu les pions vous avancez les pièces
d'activ bon relationnel axel final on ne
sait pas quoi mettre en jeu leur ont eu
et n'auront alors craint pas grand chose
non plus et l'anem fernand
qu'artificielle potentiellement si
pendant quinze jours ils font droit en
droit prend des 8es après il faut passer
vite prenez à trois
sa série
en peignoir les valaisans ils ont la
peur de tout mais ils ont adhéré
structure des fonds ne devait donc
bonbons souvent celles qui ont
d'ailleurs envahi 6-2 et pc c50 reçoit
des trains français 6
pour se rendre toutes les cases pour que
france soir elle a cédé 5 des cinq du
cavalier les pions penser ça court dans
la nasse des quatre cavaliers ancien
froid donc c'est vraiment embêtant
double less pas si grave si on arrive
bien abandonné on va quand même bien que
le plan c'est 5 des noirs contre la
casse des caps centrale en tentant de
penser être écartée si c'est aussi
important parce comme gérard genre
jamais rigolant je comptais seconde
milesi
si chez interfel les pinceaux
le mari lancer un quelconque
c6 avait 16 ans et six sur une casse
pour elle fait bander 6 donc du coup
garder l'influencé 7 mai club france 5
avec le fond blanc en c6 les noirs
contre la casse des six des 5es des cas
des temps qui ferait que les noirs ans
clément valla
a profité de ces casses avec les
vainqueurs des quatre ça se combinaient
donc
chacun à fond je
reste compliqué moi je je prêche à la
candidature n'est pas
bon moi je m'habille d'en descendre
mais revoit mais je raccompagne
d'opposition
veulent des biens sais je vous ai mal
est
plus facile à comprendre pour les
joueurs amateurs par exemple classique
si on veut vraiment sur deux sont des
choses très ténue que c'est difficile de
comprendre exactement comment à partir
de ça on peut prendre un avantage essayé
avec les blancs mais à ce niveau là bas
les blancs ils ont quatre contre trois
en fait c'est clairement leur avantage
puisque le 4 contre wade noir ça c'est
important en fait ils peuvent
difficilement l'exploiter à cause des
pions doublé en admettant qu'il mène
plus de pièces sur l'échiquier si on se
retrouvait dans une finale de roi et que
les noirs avancent et tous leurs pions
en caricaturant et les blancs tous leurs
pions ben les blancs ils seraient
facilement actions passées alors que les
noirs il serait bloqué leurs quatre
votes bloqués par les trois blancs parce
qu'ils ont des pions doublé mais bon ça
c'est du très très très long terme ils
ont en effet que les voilà les finales
avec peut-être une pièce mineurs chacun
un peu meilleures pour pour les blancs
etc après de la gagner c'est compliqué
mais pour l'instant les noix il compense
avec leur carte de fou en gros je
pensais ça
est donc ici voici étonneront championne
kim a réfléchi à pas mal sur la reprise
de pièces entre
le roi et le fou un beau ballet 2 doit
être ok a priori on
va voir ce qu'il fait plus tard on y
reviendra si tu veux on va passer à un
tout petit à ton petit chouchou à prague
et qui a les noirs contre une très bonne
chose est
sûre je dirais que notre duo
ensemble
position allemande ailleurs c'est cap
des 5 ou 7 5 6 1 alors bon je reste dans
le forez pour très original on va
aller
hélas beaucoup d'idées mais travaille
beaucoup les ouvertures c'est pas pour
rien qu'un scène n'a intégré à son
équipe de seconde en récemment au
championnat du monde
il faut encore trois sur table de
repassage
ok donc on a on a une sicilienne donc
est-ce que prague il joue aura toujours
un signal sur la carte tu dois dans le
connaître je pense
à tous ces quatre avocats
et donc fouet pousser quand on fait vrai
que ça peut paraître intuitive parce que
si les noirs arrivent à jouer des cinq
mâts et en gagner un temps et sous il
est hyper mal placé ou pelé doit
reprendre et le centre ce qui se passe
dans ma partie et le fou perdre un temps
donc en phase avec moi ça me semble
choquer mais penser ça l'est
certainement pas ce nom va devoir il
serait pas jouer ça mais qu'il est donc
c'est le coût que jouent les parents les
débutants quand il s'appelle le rapport
à celui d'alien mais
n'avait le droit de prendre ces quatre
tout ça et tendre à une mission avec
nombreux qui n'a pas envie de terminer
sa case
par la page des
comprend le sens on va vers des émotions
de fous de ça paraît évident à ces
compresseurs est arrivé 28 ans il a
plein d'une autre nature
on va voir s'il est intéressant
d'ailleurs il n'a pas changé pour ouvrir
la colonne heures n'aurait pu penser
qu'il essaie de faire ça avec il a déjà
recueilli de venir au bénin où la mort
est dit fait de la provocation normand
la provocation quand on incite
l'adversaire à jouer un coup de pioche
qui est définitive parce qu'on est
toujours notre part culoz et chacun
cette pièce donc si on est prêt à perdre
un temps pour ça faut que le coût en
question nous apprendra qu'il soit
mauvais ou affaiblissant sauf quand le
15 décembre on se dit ça un coup qu'on a
envie de jouer avec énorme puisqu'on
prend donc sa part est vraiment très
contre intuitif on
peut voir que son aîné m'a dit
j'aimerais y avoir des idées à peut-être
un peu de courage à mes côtés dont il
lui non plus mais ça qui sacrifiant qui
ont même s'il ya des choses que ce pion
par la cage des sags à manipuler les 5
nécessaires pour défendre et attaquer et
finalement il va détruire la structure
de pions de noir et or sont fous un
décès droitier shaun white a joué une
troisième fois déjà en hobby coup donc
il a fait pousser quatre baies 5 pouces
et 4 est maintenant un peu fou avec
belga julien délogeables avait les pions
bd de plus la guerre oui on peut trouver
quand même bien placé maintenant mère
carole hayes temps mais par après on
voit aussi l est pas moins de 7 ans
doublait
sont pas si mauvais
sont pas si mauvais qu'ils contrôlent
beaucoup de 15 centres un vrai toit on
en parlait dans la position de
il n'a
plus été installé à canal et rodez 5
aussi avec les noirs ou qu'un plant plus
comme pour les noirs aussi c'est
important et on va avoir 6 voix je pense
ce pion 4 en fait ils nous empêchent de
l'eau peut être même si les doubles et
qu'on aime réellement j'ai ça me paraît
compliqué parce qu'il va être défendable
assez facilement
peut-être que ça forcerait un médecin
qui sera intéressante à voir si on va
essayer de jouer un f3 en fête qui met
une mise à
jouer son jeu
en fait voilà pourquoi
ça serait un peu glissante pas souri que
les pékin qui voit son début le point
aussi c'était paraît
donc les noirs bien sûr gardent leur
avance hélas non c'est très dangereux
mais froid et voilà prise sur vos rues
at war ce moment je la nature à la
reprise d'un combat jamal avantage
injuste parce allait
changer et après du coup bah je vais
avoir
les caisses active bientôt développer la
pravda reconnaît requis développement
qui les maires ont développé une à deux
que le processus qui a attaqué le cursus
qui est arrivé avant ce qui est faible
le rock c'est catastrophique car c'est
catastrophique en terme de alors non non
ça ça m'a pas du tout le 5 avril
j'y crois pas une seconde le meilleur
coût pour les noirs ça serait d'utiliser
les règles de crown et qui est d'abord
un droit de reculer le pion de jouer à
104,7 nôtre est meilleur que dans la
position c'est pour dire c'est ainsi
qu'on trouvait sur 15 blanche même au
kivu où il
fait bon ok dans tous les cas
pollution depuis serez donc il ya un peu
plus pour les noirs mais qu est-ce qu on
peut juste bien par rapport à la
position dollars la seconde option et
thermales chênois mon programme liszt et
standards dans la crise on est
généralement voilà un joli mot on a
besoin
avec du coup la seule qui violentent
endommagé mais en échange et d'un les
noirs on parle de la paire de fou
lorsqu'elle joue bien qui va l'argent de
ses six centrales à leurs devoirs c4
mais
l'histoire des finales en 2005 et on
voit que foot et 6 donc a été jouée qui
gagne encore un temps de développement
et là encore un coup créatif quand même
il n'a pas joué par exemple les leaders
age 3 dawn ferait s'il a joué 3 h un
vivat dimanche champion
et si tu bouges millions alors qu'est ce
qu'il a prévu sûrement de jouer j'ai
trois et ça c'est les femmes disposition
si tu aurais mélodies qu'on sacrifie est
bon le roi se retrouve quand même tout
nu
il ya quatre pions quatre shows pour
l'athlète mais
c'est durant l alliance voyant moi je
sais pas qui aurait du mal à dire qu'il
est mieux ici parce que finalement
échangé la table c'est pas si mal où il
a sûrement y avoir du dernier deux tours
pour couvrir les échecs échanger les
dames n'est pas si mal pour les noirs de
ressources du diplomate à cannes comme
qui ont pas sévir au final mais tu as
une pièce de moins et arrêter voire
beaucoup d'activités
au final les pions en finale
et en finale
sont passés à mons est notamment le seul
grand concurrent
oui
mais en fait on arrache un mois je pense
que je peux expliquer avec le temps de
fêtes on veut pour le moment c'est ça et
à ce jour froid le temps dilaté à
longuenesse par l'oxydation
exactement
h3 ça va - avec f 3
mois on est maintenant à
ce que les régulateurs
en
laboratoire ce qui nous faisons deux
premières
n'ont pas vraiment que tu veux dans les
options ouvertes cette évolution il
égalerait l'odeur des gones la leaf ou
en plus longue portée que les cavaliers
et les fous ensemble vraiment du travail
tous les équipiers d'avant pas beaucoup
je voudrais ensemble aux adaptateurs
différents très forte
qu'en travaillant dans l'évolution
couverte donc j'ai de manière générale
on va pas échanger un pigment travailler
aussi facilement généralement une
concession très content de mon travail
et et après encore le considérant la
police en selle position aux élections
sont vraiment là ont bloqué
concentrerait permet alors ces années
vous serez vous de la rédaction vous a
bien bougés
en avec les fous qui sera atteinte en
pollution de l'air les fous en plus de
possibilités que
la vallée le fait est que par essence en
fait dans une finale il ya plus beaucoup
de matériel sur l'échiquier du plainte
et chante donc vu que les fonctions
d'une classe à nouveau porter qui brille
donc quand l'échiquier et
et débarrassé justement dans pion de
beaucoup de pions qui bloque pas celle
là où peuvent s'exprimer le mieux donc
c'est pour ça qu'ils sont plus forts ils
braquent ain allier pour aller d'un bout
de l'échiquier à l'autre par exemple si
l'un y l'abonnement de faire quatre
sauts alors qu'un fou il veut s'y rendre
d'un seul coup donc c'est pour ça que
généralement les fous sont quand même
plus plus puissant en finale et quand
ils sont au parterre ce que tu as des
écoles
intéressante quand les deux fous sont
côte à côte qui contrôlent ils seront
dix-huit de rayons laser qui est quand
même et quand même assez désagréable
pour l'adversaire
donc la barre de la chose qu'à moi c'est
important il faut se dire alors de zola
attendent que les fauves al 3,5 du
départ ça me semble un petit peu exagéré
puisque ouais il peut y avoir plein de
tournure différente quand même sinon les
ouvertures leaf les fous peuvent avoir
du mal à s'exprimer
vous avez vu les positions en tête à
cinq rapports de la police on line vous
peuvent bien sûr lacunaire de gameiro
peut monde de redire leur
lapointe mais rencontrant des parties
non c'est que tu peux
sinon on a
déjà été écrit avant des cio ou de malt
d'orge à sa langue des signes en france
il ya des cinq
balles par l'apparenté plus globale
intégrée pour cause il a
actionné
si tu joues à 6 mai les tories je sais
que moi m'a menacée des 5 tu peut
inclure à 6 5 4 mais ça sert x 2 plus
servir les blancs parce que maintenant
les blancs ils ont une case de retrait
pour leur fou et il ya faiblesse un peu
ici mais pau pourquoi pas en vrai c'est
une idée qui permettra aussi à l'or il
valeur du c3 ou même peut-être des
quintes en fait les bleues ont la torre
de
profiter de la perte de temps noir pour
jouer en premier au centre
d'entraînement on doit pas être gêné par
ma part la poubelle sa part de l'idée
c'est bien comprendre hugo c'est le
dessin est un bon compromis 330 hors tac
le fou est en fête
ok mais bien sûr en trois périodes
conversation assez ça fait c'est clair
mais malgré tout
des saint ambroise et bon courage
ensemble vois pas pourquoi tu devrais
empêché le film d'allégeance et ce alors
qu au bout mais eric scandés rosé sans
plus
tarder coup donc non je pense que
barack obama on a un exemple sans le son
ouais alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire voix
est ce que ces noms sont à ce que ces
mots support de ce texte c'est les deux
salut les ragots banal tu arrives à pic
pour nous pour nous à parier sur les
qualités du scion est ce que c'est qu'à
table est ce que ça le fonds
qui sont un peu lents métallique qui
auront ce n'est pas cela
[Musique]
qui va parce que c'est uniquement celui
de soufre c'est quand on parle tous les
deux ce que s'il tient ça peut être la
ta connection peut-être que tu pourras
passé à la posant sur ton téléphone
son métal s elvote ok on va bien rire
moi ça fait musicale
on verra la pause peut-être qu'on peut
faire en attendant on va finir le tour
de style avec un petit à petit j'ai ri
mamediarov
alors mais quand deux joueurs qui se
lève non aguerri qui revient table
par mois je peux pas monter ton sont
sophie lomax je crois non mais je ne
réduis page et regarder vers la
véritable hockey à tampa regarde cette
partie donc dire qu a perdu contre car
c'est l'ennemi juré nous twitter hier
aurassi alger un petit peu contre mam et
avec les blancs à commencer par canal 3
tout en souplesse lui va bien jamais
appris le centre va passer un petit peu
vite l'ouverture
ou à transposer finalement dans un
gambit table ça va être une slave qui
est choisi par la matière
ouais ok donc on à du classique justice
je me divertir beaucoup plus solide que
les deux trois premiers jours il bétonne
apple
voit pour l'instant ce faux et bien non
il y aurait derrière inception mais ils
risquent de trouver une voie de sortie
un petit peu plus tôt dans la partie
et on va voir on en a mangé ses quatre
prix a déjà commencé
hier
devant des micros gaza chef camargue g1
ok mais à priori c'est plutôt ton sont
quand même son pied est le mien aussi on
peut j'arrête car h 15 spécial mettre un
casque tout à leur impose aussi pour
voir s'ils ont le moins un point de
connexion est là c'est le seul truc
c est vraiment la connexion l'âge le
versement d'aidés phone vous devez
veiller ouais bah je pensais peut-être
mieux
alors le fortuné ou en anglais la
collection
me dit et je sens en moi
c'est ok
ok
on essaiera de voir un petit peu on va
faire une pause à une pause forcée
oui comme nous comprend avec moi après
si on peut optimiser la qualité c'est
toujours mieux mais merci quand même
très rarement on va voir
en couleurs le
cnam et les autres vocales sont
peut-être que le foot bien cette du coup
du coup qu'est ce que ça donne position
dans une position intéressante encore
jeune moi j'aime bien les blancs perso
après je joue pas du tout ce genre de
position avec les noirs c'est aussi pour
ça mais je me sentirais très mal à
l'aise à la place de ma belle fille si
je sais que c'est normal mais juste ça
ne plaît pas trop pour lui et ce qui
doit essayer de l'objectif de jouer ces
sacs ou pas pour les noirs c'est ça il
faut le savoir mais on en a parlé hier
avec avec kevin dans le live avec comme
ça
donc oui à l'idée j'avais joué contre
le premier du pays
ait
jamais joué avec des rubans un virus est
de 7 lits sont des actes gaz mandat et
j'arrivais noir c'est simple ce qui
avait versé 5 ans fait barrage entre les
pièces et on se fait des idées ça risque
de se retouver revenu tout près georges
prend par exemple de provoquer les pour
une passation et sans risque à valeant
elle allait prendre on vous prend 2 en
3h25
trois recettes est en fait dans
l'apaisement dans le sud je casse ma foi
bien peu d'âme mais si souvenez-vous en
série devil et
ouvrir une session c'est une perte de
temps
mais
l'objectif des noirs vraiment de jouer
ces sacs c'est le coup libérateur
puisque pourra s'inspirer très moche les
arriérés dans une colonne ouverte c'est
une grosse cible
et bloquent surtout le faut donc c'est
sûr que si on arrive à jouer c'est
simple la position devrait assez le cv
des dispensaires d'anglet si on se lève
ici ici se termine et si par exemple on
arrivait à mettre une autre pièce avec
les bleus en héros à prioris pas
possible ce ne serait pas un problème
pour les noirs sur cinq à voir aussi
steiger la vigne en forêt gb 4 c'est
derrière les
210 sous ce nom il ya plusieurs idées
contenues terrien
[Musique]
c-32 idée je trouvais cette étude
assistance aux
plus jeunes des quatre saisons donc moi
je suis partisan de jouer avec des 400
plus mais c'est plus d'un style
d'aureilhan pied
donc voilà c'est rémy des merlus
on a une bonne question mais jobs
comment activer le phocéen pour les
blancs
alors
moi que j'ai
enfin je veux 40 certainement où
effectivement embêté rend fous les deux
mais à cela implique de jouer des cinq
un jour est ce qu'il voit lors
d'échangés au sérieux ok je pense qu'il
ya deux options sont possibles vers
massa l'a guéri et réfléchit un moment
ça un moment créé dans la partie on va
voir quelle tournure il prend après eux
quatre billets vendus peu 5 et ça peut
être intéressant puisque les îlots
rennais deux fois ouvert en supposant
qu'anouar face le petit rock ce qui
n'est pas certain comme on l'a vu de
radars que tu as montré où le roi
powerset mais si on arrivera jamais ça
des fois avec les deux fois ouvert en
chassant opus ce cavalier qui défend le
rock à bord on peut se retrouver avec
beaucoup de pièces chez les blancs qui
pourraient pointer sur le roc noir et
donc ça peut créer une attaque
intéressante
on n'en est pas là mais ça pète un plomb
vraiment d'avancer ses pions
donc on va avoir le choix crédits redd
ici en tout cas une profonde réflexion
déclare d'un g5 de m'hamed le chat pour
rester dans l'hôtel et on voit qu'au
passage à nice il nous a écoutés il a
joué aux quatre
là je pense que j'ai 5 ça va vraiment
suicidé alors il aurait fait plus de
sens donc le pion et 1,23 pour le coup
mais ça serait marrant attendra-t-elle
où toutes les parties et jamais ils
envoient g4 ou g5
la sphère appareils comme maxime avec
ses cheveux roses
choix
bah c'est 5 à la logique
il pendant 30 ans
ouais
benjamin rouget pense que petit rock est
mauvais
ça me semble
que c'est un peu rauque et côté
cimetière corps ouais non moi je pense
plutôt que c'est 5
plutôt c5 eyed peas le paraissent les
séracs mais c'est également une position
où je serai vraiment beaucoup plus à
l'aise avec les blancs donc à hugues est
malin oui
oui mais des fois ça ne dérange pas
d'avoir du contrôle quoi mais là je
serai pleinement j'aime pas je n'aime
pas les noirs fin j'ai vraiment
difficile de position dangereuse pour
les noirs on va voir comment on m'avait
dit en ce sens à ce qui n'en titouan
dans son sac ou pas
ça m'énerve salut à toi
venu et on va peut-être du coût continue
de tourner ce stade il nous reste deux
parties qu'on n'est pas allé voir encore
sip aucun etienne qui n'ont pas encore
fait nul tu grosse nouvelle
ça à peine trois minutes
oui
retrouvez à la câble au 2 rue ce
dessin que cit p nk å peut-être hilal et
blanc il a quand même intéressant pour
lui il faut qu'il arrive à s'aguerrir un
petit peu donc il intérêt à jouer quoi
et on a encore eu espagnol
as l'impression
alors pas du tout
ma
patience des ouvertures encore frappé
non a de nouveau raté de djoko piano
rassemble je regardais très vite et vu
qu'il ya eu 1 6 maintenant on aurait pu
croire qu'une foot et du niari qu'il
allait reculer plus tard c'est un peu
pour me piéger
par des as 19 fax
a4 empêche de 5
et maintenant on joue à 5 ans pech bleu
gars 1
alors pourquoi on joue pas un style
direct qui doit être du jouable ou si je
pense à nous à 5 16 ou si elle gagne à
des idées ici avec des rendez vous aux
us
qui avait d'énormes harding exactement
ces techniques un gymkhana maxime
d'ailleurs
les thématiques l'arrêt roe l'âge c'est
paris centre ou dans la préparation sa
petite-fille naissance du coup est donc
le fameux des cats encore une fois qui
c'est toi y arriver pour les blancs le
foie reculer
four b3 et l'idée encore une fois ce
fauve et 3 d'anticipation on dirait
peut-être mais s'arrête pas si évident
que c'est par rapport à des cinq ce que
c'est aussi pour libérer la case 6 4
pour le cavalier voire plusieurs à
plusieurs raisons
raison principale c'est de le faire
reprendre les cartes pour des quatre
leaders des cinq thématiques et du coup
on veut pas perdre de temps science nous
faut être très potentiellement
généralement dans ses positions on croit
qu'on peut prendre
ces passages nuageux
pour illustrer cela donc on n'a pas
envie de se retrouver comme ça on va
être forcé du coup de réagir sur cette
personne au sens où on aimerait pouvoir
jouer le 5 du coup ce qui est possible
dans la partie en ayant l'acculant le
fourbe et 33 sur la même chose ici n'en
a pas de problème sur ce faux et ndola
ont toujours eu 5 avec une position
intéressante pour les plans
du coup ce petit coup fait trois encore
la prophylaxie on anticipe ce que fait
l'adversaire à chaque fois et
on pas à cette éventualité dont qui lui
tour est vite dans la colonne de mettre
une pression menace aux quatre
indirectement et le faou 29 arrière café
sommet d'abuja raciale c'est pas aimé
vous hier ces deux
domaines
c'est à dire autre chose ces deux
boureks défend tout simplement le pion
un pion leucate et bois terre on est
braquée sur le roi ou c'est pas ce qu'il
peut se passer des fois été par des
batteries qui peuvent se construire un
peu plus tard d'attaquer la crème des
pièces plutôt braquer sur le roi dans ce
genre de l'ouverture mais on est encore
au début au douzième coup et hutus qui
reste à faire donc on va peut-être le
plan devant ça va être comme i'll be
back je pense qu'ils vont faire le
standard s'ils y parviennent ce qu'ils
ont des problèmes sur leurs prix sur
leurs pions centraux mais le déjà activé
ce canal y est peut-être là menée par là
bas ou alors ici dans ce genre de
position je devrais peut-être plus
logique de l'amener aux c4
pour mettre pression sur le fond et sur
l'option et on passe pas par des deux
qui pourrait poser de problème parce que
ce tour il est quand même largement sous
pression au delà en d2 et bal adam des
blogs créés l'un d'âmes et où il faut
faire attention à bon
peut-être mais en fait dans la
réalisation
du coup le cac manitou va sûrement se
développer après la question c'est à
chaque fois la science cette tension
ressemble donc qu'est ce qu'on a envie
de la fête de fermer le centre d'ouvrir
ou de maintenir le statu quo a juste
choisir le bon moment pour prendre la
bonne décision home est pas encore là
j'aimerais évoluer dans le 19/20 coup
notre cas c'est cariat khimki chine ici
respect au caire un petit peu se faire
chier
mais par moments qu'ils auront plein de
réflexions karine qu'au cateau
placidement
alors on demande cahier bessin
maquillant b5
je pense qu'il a moins d'avenir qu'on
sait 4 parce que en c4 on tape comme sur
le court central
en bessin et revendique des fois les
noirs et bon jeu mais celle ci soit
aussi faut voir comment ça évolue mais
c'est pas forcément une case ici qu'on
vise spécifiquement b5
alors qu'havas c'est intéressant parce
que oui oui
c'est bien sûr il est vrai que son rôle
en dessin q c'est un peu super spéciale
c'est un réel avantage tout humaine
pression sur quelque chose dont tous les
quatre ou cinq
en fait de france et 4 aussi bien trois
défauts des relèves 50 dessins witi peut
ainsi scanner la plus d'avenir en ces
cas comme des 55 cavaliers je ne devrais
pas le dire
après c'est évidemment parce que j'avais
dit l'un des deux a pas l'affront fait à
six en mai mais le cac va lancer quatre
opus de l'avenir et possibilité que
l'on va finir une entité avec alain
grandi lui ce rapport
qu'est ce que ça va revenir au début
on a encore une sicilienne
vendée jusqu'à les blancs qui est
spécialiste bien si cela ne te laisse
pas commenter
ce
serait sympa d'avoir des rocs opposé
mais je peux jouer avec des caches ces
quatre aujourd'hui ce qu'il dira ça
tirait par de leader à qui je
travaillais ok j'ai même joué les blancs
à un essai nous expliquer du coup
pourquoi j'ai carte ici on veut mettre
le fourrage et de j'imagine en fait pas
forcément ok
j'ai trois séances et les avec malice
pense pas que c'est beaucoup de boulot
moi aussi est bon dans ce contexte donc
ça à cause de cavanac qui a fait une
très grosse partie
des trois singes et trash
hhh ans de sa journée c'est pas
normal médecin ou plus tard dans la
ligne ok
et donc j'ai qu'interpol a dûment
tchèque donc j'ai galopante a présidé la
pluie des principales des lacets
comptabilise que je connais les fils
avec édouard et bunge et son charisme de
m un simple jeu de ne prodiguer son
travail bit s'est pas trop quoi en faire
et du coup en fait le cas mais d'après m
an le sexe quand même l 3 mas est
pourquoi contre angèle six ans qu'on
voit ici un 3ème justin concret c'est un
exercice du courant fait qu'on l'instant
on connaît les quatre probables élus et
donc vous infiltrer les chèques
et et le fait que tu mets ou de la ja
désidé avec avec des caf il est des fous
ces sacs etc et vous savez que dans une
position avec notre fiscalité joël on
n'a pas trop envie de donner quatre
matchs du court après sur le deuil en
échange même trois structures
l'intéressement comme ça vient trop tard
elle et les sacs et cavaliers des 6 et 7
va rester trop indécis et ça attention
way you lie après un point bas de post
lui est alors le nord-mali cissé
mais
hcca et et c'est probablement un déclin
du coup choisi malgré ça rapporte rachid
bobards qui est
des rues
ainsi se trouver dans un air froid et il
va jouer l'effort 1,2 de production de
tablettes garder deux ou trois
jeunes auraient pu atteindre avec un
target qu'invite
6 3
alors là où ça peut être intéressant
vous avez vous comme opéra 6 buts à 1
dans le besoin de
cnc unifrance
si une
banque et une craie rupture en fait et
puis ça ouvrira les minots consolidé
parce que du coup en gros les blancs il
a joué start de coût qui peut paraître
un peu obscur mais qu'il aimerait
peut-être mal il se dit que un plus tard
dans la partie peut-être que avoir
intégré à chinon c'est bien pour les
plans et ça nous permettra une percée ça
facilitera son attaque exceptions
étaient là tels que les blancs ils
mettent plus de temps à créer une
tension
assez subtil et la jouer d'amendé 2 donc
on va peut-être avoir le souhait
exaucé debix civ qui voulaient des rock
blues les mêmes si les noirs
resté au centre aussi redon ces
variantes leroy parents ont eu vite mais
avant même grand maroc
et qu'elle a eu 5
à le voir avant
rapidement sur le roc est ce que
[Musique]
mais fou généralement il est là prend
alors le fouet parce qu elle pourra
quand même collé ou laisser schéma d'un
des deux ou trois cavaliers qui leur à
ça c'était ce schéma là avec deux cartes
3g car tout ça fait mal à ce malaise
dans la
et le fou est un monstre parce que
générale nous avons toujours rêvé de
gagner en sac à dos d'âne c'est ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est qu'une foule de 15
noir il est beaucoup plus important ici
que lui donc traction akokan tennis et
quand on va toujours être prêt à
conserver notre foot cases blanches et
sur les exceptions mais plutôt que de
perdre notre fou de cannes noirs qui la
maternelle attaque la structure
ouvre du classement
du coup franc à paris
donc s'il ya un coût à l'étranger et non
à ce tragique événement rare pour être
plus connu est
exactement
ça c'est pas s'exiler vous rejouez h à
la place le fit jouer des tours moi je
joue au hockey quand on va avoir des
revenir on va regarder
petit tour ce qu'on a pu signer la main
tous les héritiers la gendarmerie dit
alors qu'il les pièces noires dans le
challenger de produits score de 14 ans
je vous le rappelle qui a commencé donc
pas une défaite avec lena
et qui a annulé lien avec les blancs
contre un de ses frères grand maître en
étant solide donc il ya de nouveau les
noirs contre joe date gerbe qui a un
joueur danois qui aura 17 ans à peu près
encore un autre jeune talent comme plus
agile est il capable
d'accueillir rater ma mort ok
mais aussi par la licorne est haï non un
match correct qui était lourdement
oui par dumas couramment
et pour elle crée pas qu'il viendra
renforcer et à laisser les sacs de pain
noir je ne sais pas vraiment qu elle les
défend l'idée selon lui aussi ces cas où
mais en dehors oui
carrier vent décide d'oublier tout le
temps contre cela très très bizarre de
me retrouver en bout de pale ale pièce
l'ouverture aux matériaux enrobés 6 qui
me disait qu'il est normal
et on a un troisième coup
à ces contrées inconnues
mais organisés à des idées et
voir la suite donc du coup vu que contre
cette variante basse les compliqués du
vc 4 pour les morts il abandonné
et ces trois
jeux 6 6% quantifié à catastrophe qui a
été inclus ici on ne peut pas permettre
les blancs d'oeufs puis c'est une chose
qu'on regarderait du temps et notre
cavalier et ils jouent à 4 kim à la
racine naturel quand même 3 tout de
suite essayé de s'emparer du centre
ouvrir la démo darwin à béton faut donc
que 4 qui me semble un bon coup est pris
ce cavalier propre marque embraya à
jouer de lorik cana cap 6
hélas les blu aujourd hui en tout cas
l'air intéressant quand même c'est
cavaliers cinq
cavaliers c'est ça qu'ils refusent les
changes et sur les changes on peut
supposer que on prend avec eux ou lg qui
se font piéger
des pions à priori pour quand même
accélérer le développement
est-ce que trop mal et cela pourrait
prendre du plomb gerber
dans des propos à paraître sur le prix
naturel et docks et c'est ça qui a été
joué donc
intéressant mais une pression sur 17 on
interdit à un peu sortir
et
si jamais métaux et peignoirs moi j'ai
dit ok je vais septembre était tout de
suite tant qu'à y être ce qu'elle allait
il va revenir en d3 et en fait on a cet
avant poste 5 est très intéressant il va
pas bloquer notre fou puisque notre faut
il l'avouer année sur la grande des
nappes taies façon parce qu'autant pouce
droit en fait les deux et que la
noire de
marque canada qui est le sien 15h10
s'ils jouent aussi c'est dans le four à
sentir à l entraînement et si je suis et
j'ai six les masses c'est une prison de
l'état parce que la structure qu'il
aille à 5,6 c'est une structure un petit
peu de ce camp nou n'a qu'à regarder
et donc il avec
6,6
mais
pourquoi pas vraiment car les
17,6 manège avec notre canal en tout cas
il veut pas rentrer tard qui va le voir
oui c'est ça et après on veut
et puis on te s'il était surpris donc on
va voir s'il arrive à trouver une bonne
réaction sur l'échiquier embarquant
d'ailleurs puisqu'il n'a pas l'air de
connaître ce coup en tout cas qu'une
heure disons qu'il ya quand même pas mal
réfléchi on arrive au bout ça évolue
merci jean françois
pour le message à passer coule depuis
500 points c'est pas mal déjà écoute on
commence le deuxième donc j'espère que
tu refera plus 500 points avec moins
tendre les 1400 et puis à chaque bouquin
3 500 points d'andy 6 2 6 3 4 ans montre
comment trappe
hop une
[Musique]
page de pub mais je l'aï mentionné
dès aujourd'hui dans quelques minutes
ouais alors que ces six minutes la pause
on peut rire doit donc on s'est
renseigné d'ailleurs elle nous reviendra
on verra comment la partie de manille
s'est voulue mais a tout de suite qui s
[Musique]
et
il
[Musique]
à
le oh
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ok mon micro est coupée
on est de retour
si tout va bien vous devriez nous
entendre de nouveau
il ya cette partie doute car c'est
justement micro sérieux s le
s que son
buzz
ou
alors du coup on va essayer de retrouver
où on en est et
j'en suis heureux mais tu pas retenu le
groupement c'est pas ton micro du
week-end amèrement c'est à cause de la
connexion
même pierre hargoues pack sinon tu
reviens comme avant mais
pour en revenir à notre parti je sais
pas ce que tu peux faire
je sais pas ce que tu peux faire
en tentant en écho est très bas
et voir monter dedans de nouveau juste
pour bien désolé les problèmes pour
pouvoir ça vient de chez stouff
pas trop ce que je peux faire pour
t'aider
ces morts tous les paramètres sont
normaux pour toi
bourrelière à écouter calme revenir à la
partie en attendant des six a été joué
donc ça on avait
beaucoup de quoi
assiste donc le coup que tu me disais 12
employés l'hymne avec les noirs que kara
scène
utilise entre son auteur on était resté
je crois faut trois derniers cours
développement et tour élite
classique très vite dans l'espagnol je
passe ici va faire se planquer à ses
standards rappeler aux fonctions de
kétou aussi de contrôler toutes les
cases de bronze en europe
et qu amélie b d2 ou qui termine son
développement d'atrenta et bouffe et a
été joué au libéria pour
moi ajouté des pensions et donc
peut-être que ça suivra plus tard
dame c2 est
fou et 6 bon
on voit que 45 1h25 à la pendule donc ça
c'est assez intéressant contre 56
billets de seulement temps d'où là ça
veut dire que champion du monde il doit
être plus ou moins dans une de ces
prépas peut-être du championnat du monde
et dans intérieur donc qui lui est
familier
après ça
en
terme d'éco je peux tu ressens un peu la
solution miracle
du passeur de banqueroute ce que tu veux
dire par
poker que les sept autres glings
tu peux un petit peu bleus faisait
jamais gagné contre un adversaire très
fort ça marchera on bluffe
au niveau des buteurs oui
alors donc fossiles sont en tout cas
d'enquêté jeu par bacchus donc on
propose de supprimer des chicanes et
coudekerque branche et à la question
pour duda c'est ce qu' il a joué comme x
4 regardez les faux et fort c'est
certainement la foux 17 ans il ya
vraiment ce courage qui est
problématique on n'aurait pas d'autre
choix chez les noirs mais comment
continuer ensuite
parce que pour les dames qu'en terme de
tours avait disparu de l'échiquier ce
qui fait d'eux que la gouverneur est ce
qu'il faut les prendre est-ce qu'il faut
qu on essaie de jouer pour le centre est
vide et 4 ça paraît pas forcément
évident de créer quelque chose de partir
cette position est assez terne mais
normalement il peut quand même des
petits problèmes pratiques pour les
noirs vu que c'est l'argent ou n'ai pas
vu sa meilleure chance contre 15 c'est
mon match même si les gâchettes reste à
voir si nous devons être plus inspiré
que le challenger us
en tout cas
y'a pas forcément garde de connaître ou
alors ils peinent à se rappeler
et l'option d'échangé les fous du coup
apparaissent de nouvelles questions
doigt parce que je pense que les deux
prises peut-être avoir du sens
prendre du clos deux ex les plis un
petit peu le roi mais ça ramène en
promotion pour essayer de jouer de
dessins qui vous plonge dans une
position 30 de la tour b c c'est pour
maintenir le statu quo en termes de
structure la colonne pour la tour à tour
qui sera bizarre aussi se mêler
passerait sûrement pas sa vie donc avoir
avoir le choix de duda délaisse pas sûr
du tout qu'il échange fois quatre
options
poésie ne toucher à rien et vous trouvez
abrutis parce que pour l'instant il est
défendu
une position compliquée je trouve
tout reste à faire
on va changer peut-être d'échiquier on
va voir comment sont développés avec
quoi comme partie les doubles sorties en
car elle ya trois types de l'espace
qu'on va retourner
du wef qui a traduit plus
regardées l'échiquier dans sa tête ça
marche mieux apparemment
on va retourner à cavalia traces qui
était vraiment cookies est surpris et
finalement
a pris 1,12 ibos nous sommes n'est pas
forcément
plus évident on prendre
il a pris donc il a décidé de donner son
beauf ou de casse droite pour un petit
peu admirez structure de plumes blanches
jeu de chance pour toi tu peux tenter le
pic au hasard et que l'on verra jusqu'à
kehl où tu montes sur trois
dames cet été j'ai joué
j'imagine qu'un
jour
il n'a pas manqué tout de suite les
développeurs ont pris goût à l'autre
je pense que
là on parle de poker et encore on peut
tu iras qu elle était jouée doux place
un intéressement pour le coc a analysé
et qui peut paraître surprenant au
premier abord je pense je passe dans le
tchat
nous allons penser qu est ce que je
pouvais vous inspirez c'est caraïbes et
vite c'est bizarre on a une pièce qui
bien que développée sur une classe
naturelle on la ramène au bercail plutôt
que de finir son développement en
sortant par exemple sauf ou encore
pourquoi je laisse cavaliers devaient
vite qui peut sembler mystérieuse
explique-nous il est le maître stratège
déclaré beat
gerber dans l'ordre oui mais
l'ajustement des normands dans une
espagne un autre
[Musique]
message
ouais c'est l'idée ce cavalier mais
sûrement qu'être le remette en ce sens
du coup que supposé
j'imagine n'a pas trouvé pourrait le
mettre d'autres un terme à une année là
bas
tous mes livres et
[Musique]
autres cas des deux joueurs qui sont
très créatifs en partie
iv notre lady moving
comprends
c'est la partie qui va peut-être la plus
intéressante on va voir comment ça
continue un petit peu donc il a joué
deux des quatre ça paraît logique les
noirs sont en retard en termes de
développement dans l'interview ouvrir
les lignes
qui revenu en 17
il fait le même rôle consiste quant à la
défense du plomb ou 5 mais
voilà peut-être qu'il va partir là bas
je crois qu ensuite je savais qu'elle
était joué donc ça nous paraît un peu
peut-être pour une de ces idées autour
d'elle on écoutera mon naturel entrant
la colle à une pression sur ses pions et
ici du coup visite ils m'ont clairement
qu'avec les noirs il n'est pas venu là
pour tripoter joue g5
salut pour barreaux au passage dont 10,5
et d'où peut-être que ce qu'elle va lire
il veut aller en justice comme on avait
aussi évoqué alors j'ai faim d'amour le
voit reculer le sacrifice n'aurait aucun
sens puisque le nord dont par ok donc
nourrir et les lignes sur le
sur le roi blanc du scotch chose et en
plus on n'a pas de vraie pression ici
parce que justement ce qu'a lyon 17 y
défend il défend son compère donc a pas
de problème donc il a évidemment rideau
rouge les trois
et
j'ai dit pour le coup pas de bluff
milliards actions à prendre il le prend
à part donc là on va avoir une position
extrêmement chaudes
juste qu'on va venir c'est l'amérique
était jusqu alors cru et donc un jour au
g5 qui s'est déclenché
donc il donne la possibilité de l'ange
espions ce que dubaï a priori à ignorer
en disant que c'était trop dangereux on
va dans lequel des deux a raison
après sa
[Musique]
mort
la vidéo pour se transcender des voix
les rend si bien que
les plus en
retard de développement et des lignes
qui sont sans s'ouvrir pour les foubrac
là c'est vraiment une partie à trois
résultats ans le couple est plus logique
très dame ces deux pour développer la
dame défendre le pion attaqué cavalli
ont fait du troisième vingt
et à voir la ici c'est vide ils décident
d'échanger
d'ailleurs sur les choses ça serait
intéressant généralement vous recommande
d'autre du courage à ses parents
systématique mais la plupart du temps
nos jours nos positions mais il se
reprend de piotr ferait à mon avis plus
sens pour avoir les deux colonnes
ouverte pour les tours doré
compensation pour le pion intéressante à
la personne pour les dons tous les jours
genre de position même si certainement
objectivement équilibré mais d'un point
de vue pratique et les mains
ça me semble
absolument pas mal il faut qu'on me
demande de remettre ton micro finalement
comme anormal
oui peut-être
ok on commande est là est donc double
ici qui a fléchi pour hilla ya plus de
30 minutes d'avancé la pendule donc il a
raison il a surpris son adversaire dans
l'ouverture ex cavaliers à 3 et
maintenant il a un vrai combat je pense
être de type de position qu'il espère
obtenir donc il doit être assez content
même si un petit peu la moue
mais particulièrement passionnante
j'y reviens l'ambition de
[Musique]
se relancer
plus tard alors
on s'est dit avant
[Musique]
on a récupéré ce tout en espérant qu'ils
reviennent avec une voix soit il
caractérise
nous venons saccadé et en attendant on
va regarder ce qu'il faut dont deux
américains dans leur douleur berlin
karrada et chaud cloud qui a forcément
la partie la plus excitante je vous
concède nous est à 46 tours on était
resté sur tours 18 des champions qui
réfléchissent et comment de prendre la
tour les deux options a semblé possible
de choisir avec le fou d'amour qui n'a
pas fait seul
droit propre les sketches et un espèce
de grand lac artificiel a pris de front
autour d un radis qui prend l'accolade
le fou qui aura bien un set et donc du
coup en fait ce qui est intéressant
c'est de dire que champlain il a estimé
que la tour était mieux placé à
l'endroit où peut-être soutien déception
là plutôt que aïda boubane pour
s'échanger à tours adverses qui
finalement est dans une belle colline
verte mais elle lui dit bah tu as tout
ok elle tape sur du vide et ça repart on
a récupéré stouff on va attendre qu'ils
nous fassent le plaisir de parler pour
savoir ça se passe mieux je suis là
vraiment c'est vrai que moi je t'entends
traiteur donc c'est pour ça que j'aime
chez je sais jamais
ça marche bien on pas ne pas voir
l'enfant malheureusement
et que vous pouvez nous dire
la soirée
devait être jouée par fin dit
quoi et
3,3 pour faire
ses preuves
et de sueur hkd on croit sûrement g4 et
sinon peut-être qu'un jour un g4 ou même
pour venir la 4g 5 me à ce moment là on
concédera akadjé quatre bogeys mais la
raison principale en bois qui puissiez
vous voulez pas se fixer aux attentes
nous les pasteurs fixé comme ça il y
aura une prise en passant
là pour illustrer le pion de rage se
retrouve
jean a joué dans laquelle l'or on
voudrait
donc donc car on a joué le petit ya
beaucoup de petits coups prophylactique
dans toutes ces paroles
des petites subtilités à la différence
qu'il a joués g3 et tanger vite sont
comme qui justifie sa reprise tout à
l'heure du fou donc sa tour est plus
difficile parce qu'il veut jouer les
5% de toutes ces pièces sont sur la loi
donc ça paraît logique et qu'un radar à
lui interdire aux gens qu'à méditer sac
alors on pensait qu'il y aurait
peut-être un écho var
si je me coupe ça tu pense qu'on va tout
entendre du tout mais je peux tenter un
dans la hotte foot non
c'est défendre tu penses quoi il n'y pas
de contester devant lui pour qu'il
annule ils ont produit leur effet est ce
que est ce que vous nous entendez
toujours à mon avis
on a
dit la confiance
ces fiches devaient le string les
pelouses est prévue demain n'est pas
noir qui nous surveillent une demande de
me de me coiffer
et est-ce que c'est mieux du coup est-ce
que ça rien changé est-ce qu'il ya moins
d'écho chez ce touch
bon
on va voir si c'est vrai que les justes
et les moins c'est devenir la partie du
coût way you kg 5 de jouer donc le
meilleur moyen d'empêcher l'adversaire
de se mettre sur une cassette d'y aller
soi même au premier donc c'est ce qui a
fait fabi a assis son cavalier au g5 en
me disant non qui poussera pas ton pion
à rien changé du tout est ok
et du coup ici il veut pas donner son
fou déclare qu en limite et les blancs
ramener leur second cas ralliée au
centre aux libéraux qui ont passage
contrôlé cette casque peut être une case
intéressante des fois les noirs veulent
mettre en pièces et pour on voit que les
blancs de l'espace
qu'une noire soit on peut regrouper mais
repliés sur eux mêmes ça reste difficile
de percer pour les blancs on verra
comment ça se passe
sa réaction je vais remettre pour voir
et si je trouve ça
ce que ça change quelque chose n'allait
pas un micro à
ok
un appel de l'éditrice pour les slogans
liés ça va refuser nous avons à plus
tard
ok double à 7 pouces chacun ses
standards du bas-rhin
position mais n'y a pas forcément de
grosses nouveautés ici donc on va plutôt
attendre que que ça se développe pour
devenir que c'est pascal plus
passionnant je reconnais les ventes
restent peu près le nombre d'acquis mais
l'air sympa
on va aller voir ce que font les deux
jours du tournoi je sais pas vendre
notre preview chris pine quoi
tracks le cadet en tous les cas
ça se trouve c'était mieux ce que j'ai
donc je vais essayer de finir a tout
fait ces réglages à ploemeur
sinon c'est la caméra qui bouge beaucoup
n'a pas tenté notre ami notre ami prague
de repos l'année ce qu'est ce qui se
passe rapidement vous avoir en
56 minutes deux roues vous arrosez
on retrouve à pérols
maintenant au premier ok pour l'avoir
avalé les cours ok et grands les
deux sont du coup les plus belles à mars
ou revient avec une meilleure qualité
hockey a tout de suite
[Musique]
et
en
[Musique]
on
laisse parler
son talent
ok donc on est revenus là le micro les
ports et les mets
[Musique]
fait
dans un instant donc on est la pollution
est vraiment forest reprend un mandat
donc on voit que le fou
et français
classé j'ai passé à changer quelque
chose
le fond d'un vieux oui
mon roi que les dents pour apprendre
plus
une foule mais si c'est pas une bonne
note placement
intéressant
mais la
porte arrière
pour le savoir ok
ok ok
si chez moi c'est moyen il me
fallut une partie était hyper
intéressante qui vous en rappeler pour
ceux qui tels au début du stream je
reviens vite ventes regrette avait
sacrifié un pion dans l'ouverture ils
avaient joint bizarre il avait joué sur
food dans ces quatre qui avait terminé
de coire bouger trois fois dans leurs
clubs
se fout là mais il avait quand même
gagné un pion en échange la structure de
des nord avec de détériorer on avait vu
qu'il y avait eu ce coup là donc attaque
ou h2o ne ferais ça va jouer gros achats
en disant si tu manges temps ferme
c'est mieux mais encore de l'éco
cavani m6 qui ces trois
3 thierry
n'ont heureusement mon roi finalement
c'est 200 aimerait mieux il a dit oui le
pré trade là et après une enquête c'est
moi kbc sont
donc c'est le
hockey
c'est pas trop
ok ok
ben je vois moi je peux rien faire
donc ouais c'est vrai dire la partie
- ouais je sais pas trop après hier
pendant ton stream c'était par moments
aussi quand je regardais quand kevin
mesdames on s'était dit qu'à l'est
d'autres c'était sa cadette donc je ne
sais pas ça dans ta connection peut-être
juste ce
tournoi j'ai pas acheté explications et
à u15 quand je vais chez les noirs
salut darko cor ne doit pas à eux cinq a
été jouée doogie il ouvre deux sont fous
de calonges on va avoir une position
très chaude f3 on en parlait au début du
live qui est logique on est prêt à
échanger tant pis pions doublé mais le
but c'est d'ouvrir la lingua sacrifier
action on veut des compensations on veut
l'activité il a décidé de croquer assez
logiquement j'imagine qu'à détroit quel
suivi est infligé cinq peut-être qui va
arriver bientôt foule 6 donc ici les
petits prizee abouba j'en ai rien à
[ __ ] de ma structure ah bon ce qui
m'intéresse c'est peut-être d'ouvrir à
l'idée de me faire une méga cadre des 5
6 qui s'est passé donc il a des petits
carrés a qui sont pas très jolis seins
faites pas ça chez vous
et au moins il se dit qu'ils n'avaient
qu'à ceux des 5 pour le quart est
quelqu'un de sympa cette can c'est un
vertige d'un petit pattern géométriques
cas c'est assez joli
il ya un trou de plus en plus mais il ya
une pièce d'or un peu la gueule c'est ce
fou pour rester bloqué du coup peut-être
que lui va amener à se sacrifier mais
c'est pas sûr que les blancs père
médecin du tout ils vont peut-être
bloqué ce faux pour l'instant du
week-end très moche de 6
c'est une position intéressante vraiment
déséquilibre est fou g5 a été joué on
voit qu'il ya pas découverte montrant
chante ici si vous faudra juste notre
dame avec les blancs c'est pas grave
pour rien nous attaquer
dernier set elle était jouée à sequalum
17 il veut peut-être il protège chaque
jeu pas trop comment ils voir si chris
fou
voilà dame 17 à part des fonds de situer
un peu de mal à parler des jeux près ce
que tu en penses
dans le décès de céder ma région sa part
kamal al issawi
mais pourquoi parler
ils veulent se relancer pourquoi pas qui
décide pour ramener le
hockey
à cette frange et il a pris l'eau et
ouest c'est une décision responsable
intéressant stratégiquement parlant en
disant aux cavaliers domine largement
ton faux
et alors là on reprend dû piocher à
praia nanda pourquoi on prend du plomb
parce que en fait surprendre si on
reprenait la toile ce qui serait
catastrophique c'est que du coup
maintenant la case de 4 elle devient
incontestable et donc le quart à lille
va être monstrueux cartes aura plus
jamais de piot qui peuvent venir dans la
colonisation pour le chant c est donc là
il dominera mais complètement le fou
adverse
bien sûr on va bouger la dame d'abord
met donc le quality marivaux 4 ce sera
catastrophique d'un point de vue
stratégique c'est pour çà il prend du
pion pour avoir la possibilité de jouer
au fc pour chasser les cavaliers
n'hésite pas grave mon roi je le cachais
en bas âge suite et je vais mettre mes
tours peut-être dans un objet si besoin
un lieu qui avait lieu 4 et ben il n'a
pas traîné il a immédiatement chassé par
f5
et on va voir maintenant comment ça
continue encore une position
intéressante
j'aime beaucoup les formations
en tout -
n'a plus de sens droit de couvrir
que casser avec lui
donc il est important pour
le clairement on a beaucoup de déchets
qui a trois résultats et donc oui inde
d'art quoi comme on sait le cavalier
pour l'instant plus fort que le fou mais
c'est pas s'il a dit dans cette position
parce que basée spescha c'est donc il y
aura peut-être la case c4 qui est quand
même intéressante mais vous êtes aussi
dominant caen le 4 et ce fou peut-être
qu'il va réussir à s'activer un joueur
qu'on arrive à pousser les pions donc il
n'est pas définitivement condamné il
peut aussi revenir par ici pour défendre
l'euro a abandonné donc là dans l'état
des choses il est pas beau le fou mais
il ya un jour où peut-être que il va se
transformer en prince charmant et sa vie
va prendre une tournure plus agréable on
va voir comment ça évolue
ok j'en appelle te voir en acquérir
mamediarov peut-être qui peut être
intéressant il y avait des choses à
l'ouverture aussi qu'ils étaient
prometteuses à le petit aniche et
enfoncé dans sa chaise
pressé de reprendre là où on en était
on en était à
voilà exactement ici venez cheveux 4
donc on a bien dit dans l'idée peut-être
même déjà que cinq plus tard 6 mai les
noirs font le petit roi pour ouvrir la
position
et l'enjeu c'était pour régnante de
jouer ces cinq à tout prix donc il a
joué forcé vite pour préparer ces cinq
fonds
est ici guy arrivent ils à miner une
amie mais un jour à troy le petit minet
qui minent
il a joué à a3 l'idée c'est sûrement
d'ouvrir la colonne berne peut-être pour
mettre de la pression
sauf que ces cinq de jouer par la neige
la réponse agressive et il a envie de
bien des bus de d'ouvrir ce faux
sacré carrément des copies casse ont ici
dirait appris on sait ça qu'une fois
pris ils ont été surprises en cela qu'on
a tout changé
et apprend des caps ouvrir la colonne ce
qui fait que ici il faut prouver qu'un
possible alors déjà là c'est là la
petite tactique de sprint de problèmes
deux chaises comme aux arcs où le damas
quatre classiques double attaque pour
gagner nous faut
donc
évidemment et yahoo il a reculé sont
fourbes et 6 reste au passage à la
défense de ses pions donc il a sacrifié
un pion certes ce sont deux pions double
est
donc on a une position intéressante et
dumas espérait bien sûr roque est
certainement très vite moi j'aime bien
les blancs parce que même maintenant
mieux merci merci sauf à brûler vive
arrivé voilà exactement riazor qui reste
une faiblesse sur le long terme alors
même s'il ya un moment tu sais que c'est
pas marrant fait des promesses le
friterie du cabaret en fait c'est la
base le sac il veut être le gars à
liessies c'est un partenaire de paix
doit revenir au pays je n'ai pas de
raison et malgré cet accroc coin certes
c'est le sacre à ce dont on parle trop
forte
l'intérêt
c'est un saint vallier ce qui m'arrivait
souvent pensé connaissions donc pour sa
marque prend 1,5
il faut comprendre un accès
et mais en fait pour quoi que je dise et
de lausanne et allaman pour éviter ces
sacrifices les noirs pourrait garder le
3e set
et après le 9 ou
m de dépenses
se font maintenant il est plus à la
défense du roi et que pu revenir par là
bas donc c'est quand même
quelque chose d'assez osé mais par des
médias prend le risque au terme d'un
défenseur s'il fait le petit roy qui
leurs actions qu'à l'aller quoi elles
sont guerrières on vient de le voir
stouff nous l'a dit peut le chasser a
donc c'est dangereux
et ça a écrit john qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qui peut jurer par eux cinq
tout de suite
ou est-ce qu'il va attendre le rock
peut-être juste place et prend la
colonne des buts du fou j'ai cinq
enfants il a son pion attaqué aussi donc
soit il ne pousse soyez le défendre
soyez cloud
et on nous demande pour le dress code
dans ce tournoi est ce qu un dresscode
pose pas moi je sais pas
parfois sur les gros event de la fille
diana il ya déjà eu des scandales par
les pacéens mais pour ce tour 2 voilà qu
organiser du coup par le tata steel
je suis patient serait que les joueurs
et surtout bien habillé à prodware
généralement c'est plutôt les teckels
convoi de baic va dire aux shorts et que
c'est donc alors que maintenant c'est
dans cette optique le tournoi
généralement il est vrai que
bon les joueurs savent
pas qu'il y ait un moment à des fins de
vente être implicite
en quoi qu'il en dise oui ou du moins il
vous faut montrer que l'on dit comme ça
mais mais je pense que chaque joueur
c'est que il doit être
correcte par exemple où on peut être
qu'il y avait moins de chance j'étais là
tracy non un parti c'est ma quinzième
victoire
ou où ils vont en trouble arrêt de la
radio ce qui est primordial pour l'amour
l'argent est là et il est arrivé en
chance il fallait pas en chante ou
bermuda
en
jean et en remettre
mais les hangars votre email au moment
des deux d'être habillé et il aurait
cramé il a remué les adhérents et à
l'ail et le fait des histoires noms des
quelques années avec le lien entre des
travailleurs qui vient au sérieux en
chance et un langage et du mandat les
d'escalier ayons pu
travailler et non et ils pouvaient
tranchant
il a rassuré j'ai recruté et du coût des
denrées à l'amont une autre fois que
deux
d'autres choix ou bien dans une règle
d'un bien
comprendre
et du coup le convoyeur dans la baston
vous choisi kevin à lyon paparazzi alors
de la gallina d'abord en gros une épaule
est nul comme telle et du coup il est le
désir est à vos yeux donc quand même
canadien à valence
sa lettre est envoyée non les crises
internes à se trouver là c'est plus
comme icône au second ce
moyen de détecter des problèmes parce
que j'aime pas qui travaille de son côté
je les meubles et un peu
c'est sympa la prise d'entente sur la
soirée sur la mi
mai
et quand manettes le oui on est bien à
un mix entre la
restonica
à remettre mon
mieux
alors
maintenant je pense que
apparemment c'est tout
et normalement maintenant les gens vous
devez bien entendre s'amuser mois
est-ce que vous pouvez confirmer mon job
c'est le blog sa
1000e
[Musique]
section foot c'est beaucoup mieux c'est
mon petit monde à la règle qui me guide
quel génie
six amis en vain pasqua et ça mais on
attendait pas
est ce que c'est ce qu'on entend ça nous
apparemment on comprend pas
et hélas là on a vraiment tendre
là je pense que oui
mon côté de ça la logique de la
logiquement oui mais
voilà
est et ouest comptant toujours pas renié
sa manière de garder les taux
bas par rapport au fait tu vois pas
comment franchement
j'étais à sarajevo je me réfère on a
quand même c'est déjà reste déjà plus
déjà fait sur mon micro en bois
ou en patinage la ceni partout
ok
on va changer compte deux parties on a
grandi je ce rapport
va peut-être au passage mes amis
qui étaient assez chaud aussi
j'ai trouvé de traduction de l'un ou
l'autre qui crée de l'économie avait des
écouteurs oui bon il y avait mon bilan
flatteur en fait apparemment sa 1000e
point de salut pour sa viande eu du sens
que tu reprends ce méchant recrute à ce
point micro il est
en fait là on me dit à mon rythme 10 mai
on
va sentir rejeté de son casse et a de ce
fait les clowns
apparemment là c'est bon on entend les
deux des co mais il n'a pas encore le
berceau du coup je fais jamais cas ce qu
elle est comme ça par an ça alors là on
est nickel banon la jeune branché
casques bleus la branche est du coup là
on peut pas monter de temps
bougez plus c'est bon il a dit quoi
que branches les plus de côté là
c'est les joueurs les échos fait là j'ai
brossé le casque et je le mets par
aucun sens
elle en fait c'est parce que ça faisait
double sortie du club peut-être
il ya une sortie qui est bouché
je m'entends bien mais pas de chez moi
en réseau aucune âme et c'est toi qui
m'as tu en fais règle est donc c'est
bien de ta faute
bah oui passons
ok
c'est quand même assez mystérieux
exact partenaires banquiers joies du
direct
on a quand même essayé de comprendre
exactement
enfin qu'est ce qui vous était
essentielle pour la prochaine fois
ok
on peut se réintéresser peut être à
partir il n'y a pas eu aura que vous
avez à proposer un on en était par la
partie dame de 200 ans et ella
ella diehl us il a balancé f4 wah wah
wah à weedon un pion au coeur bref si
les ignorent complètement son projet 4
et il a le coup là le vous proposés par
les noirs et juste le coût de la
ratisser fou picardie la peur
l'ordinateur complètement
trop fort
ou beckham ou l'ordinateur si on 25
également les points 4 travaux est
solide et donc l'idée c'est de clouer et
que sur le plan comme l'a dit stop on
mange ici on joue sur le clouage
hélas les blancs sont obligés de bouger
la ramène pas trop bonne qu alors qu'est
ce qui se passe chez eux ils n'ont pas
de bonnes cases en fait à chaque fois on
va prendre en jugement coup pour
illustrer n'importe juste pour montrer
que sur la prise prise et on va
récupérer cette tour
56 - 12e manche à la tour
ce pion aussi qu'il va être faible une
position complètement sauvage ce
qui paraît ya quand même beaucoup de
pions un pour les noirs si on prend sa
note par exemple il ya une tournée trois
pions
contre font cavalier salut
à part une petite broutille dessous
après 1 200 moteurs avec un peu bizarre
un bug que je pense que tu aurais bien
été content d'hésiter
kevin parce qu'on n'a pas
en tout cas ça marche très très bien
bragdon questionner chrono tu vois là
j'ai vu guéri nage pas statué la partie
de bancoule un appartement à
et ses 20 ans reste un doute
oui c'est ça et on espère tous avaient
de coacher travaux deux poulains
respectifs ah oui défi ce jour-là invite
le coup du come ensemble est
devenue noire
comprenant siens à rennes plaindre mais
c'est quand même devant injuste pourquoi
n'y avait pas être camélia strange et 4
ici quelques crochets 4 pardon et l'idée
l'idée de grandes et plus ou plus posée
même si c'est vraiment complexe danser
la crise de pions et mais dure à peu le
prépare à la maison c'est peut-être de
jouer eux cinq pour refaire une pression
là-dessus
mais l'idée est d'amener un cavalier là
donc on va admettre cet échange par
exemple ce cavalier manque de guez matin
maintenant que j'y pense mais il me
semble que
j'avais on m'avait filé un dossier sur
cette ligne avec jets 4 blanc
qui vient de toucher ce terrible et il
me semble maintenant qu'on le moins
terreur si
il me semble que
que ce ses vidéos avec devait être pas
grand d'hélios lui-même un week-end où
il devrait connais
il semble bien que c'est ça et si c'est
le cas et bab sort de cette ligne avec
les 4 1/2 de purger cap ça me parle
et
et je me demande si
c'est comme ça ça me parle
je ne sais pas mais je sais pas
qu'est-ce qui perd complexe mais dans
cet ordre de coup ce n'est peut-être pas
si donc s'appliquer la foulée 4 à partir
du coup il ya une turbine bien que
puissante il a estimé que la ligne on
vient de voir qu'il mettra complexe qui
donne un gros déséquilibre matériel donc
on en était par ici bas peut-être que
que une grosse turbine dit que
finalement ça va pour les plans à long
terme parce que les pièces mineurs sont
très actives et difficile matter of est
basse et c'est rien c'est possible
qu'ils aient travaillé ses grands dieux
sont d'amour mais du coup ils étaient
prêts à rentrer dedans sans être inquiet
toujours est il que notre ami richard
rapport il n'est pas du tout rentrer là
dedans il a joué le plus
fin le moins ambitieux ducale moins
risqués cavaliers c4
il ya eu échange ça vous pouvez certes
on est maintenant donc encore une fois
il n'a pas peur de sacrifier le plus
joué cinq
jours ah si seulement à qui je ne serais
bien
et du coup après il faut définir les
mots interdire il n'a peut-être beaucoup
amélioré sur cinq cette fois ci
rapporte il a été il a payé pour voir il
a créé le pion ouais en fait thématiques
clés ce qu'il veut c'est grâce à eux ça
qui est vraiment viser les cases noires
et la traque des six des poissons à ce
fou qui en défense donc c'est pas
siégeront comment va exploiter ça ouais
tour g1 a été jouée qu'une passion son
faux bond était un peu compliquée à part
de me ramener ans j'étais trop passif
pour le coup après avoir sacrifié
réaction on sent un peu obligé de
justifier par des coins actifs donc il
abandonne son fou il mise tout sur sa
paire de chevaux
mais le relais et surtout c'est ça qui
est rude en europe ou ailleurs oui
sûrement poussé sol pour pour courir
avec
c'est dans l'air ce qu'il faut c'est sa
opg les merveilleux qui arrivent et
va-t-il arriver
c'est en fait le foot en restant a
écrite pour l'instant pour garder les
cages
bessac ezoua la place il ya eu quand
même barre des 5 go go développer le fou
dans la grande diagonale et grands à
d'encore une position à nos combats
pareil avec 3 est impossible la foulée
ça devrait quand même suivre à priori
sans trop tarder pour au moins se donner
la possibilité de manger ce cavalier
s'il arrive là
où il ya un pion de moi donc pour pour
les blancs mais il ya quand même des
baies compensation westerwelle s'est pas
trop à l'est ont dérobé thé avec ce
projet c'est peut-être on va devoir g6
d'ailleurs à un moment donné où c'est
une position complexe mais en pratique
la peine alléchant pour les blancs
qui leur arrivait à les meilleurs
d'entre eux d'eau c'est le meilleur
ouais
ça
[Musique]
gagnera-t-il à prendre il m'a dit que
que ta vie était digne d'une saga donc
je n'en doute pas j'ai fait une saga
mystère exactement
innover l'argentine hors
du coup bon ben on n'est pas encore sûr
fabien part on vient de passer famille
donc on va pas y revenir tout de suite
tout de suite je sais que c'est un bis
et le joueur très nette
de notre avis a gagné star
est ce qu'on pourra le voir un petit peu
partout en france est mort a dit
exactement dans plus la position super
intéressant on en était resté à quai
c'est simple qui aurait fait pas mal
réfléchir
et il a fini par jouer j'avais pensé je
n'ai pas osé les dimanches le
l'agressif e5
ok alors qu'à une réponse intéressante
il entretient j'ouvre mon fou j'ai aussi
à déstabiliser espion si le défenseur à
deux tons cavaliers et si j'y prends
avec lecavalier
il ya un petit cook et qui est assez
sympathique c'est qui est important
c'est d'amd 5 on met une pression au
profit de ce coup j'ai 3 mais
l'impression sur la toile et on voit la
pression sur sur les deux cavaliers à
anglet il allait réveiller le matériel
c'est si des failles d'un f3 et ben
j'aurais d'un coin dégâts exactement des
matériels et avaya 3
5 5 millions servent de ma part beaucoup
mais dans un sens oui entreprendre et
j'ai quatre ans que tu gagnes plein de
temps les prix mediative joue vraiment
sur les garde-temps tut active la salle
r
trop mézard pour les noirs pour dire
peut
on aller un peu vite a juste le problème
principal ici c'est que c'est le pion
aux des quatre îles surcharge c'est à
dire qu'il défend les deux canaris à la
fois donc si on en mangerait défendra
plus l'autre il ya encore un troisième
problème c'est la tour donc dans toutes
ces raisons en fait le gouvernement
c'est assez c'est bien joué de la part
de marc andré ac la réponse la plus
tranchante
et c'est vrai que tous les autres coûts
avait l'air assez passifs et il aurait
certainement été nommé en gros problème
très bien donc il n'avait pas l'air des
planets qu'il a beaucoup réfléchi donc
il ya trouvé sur l'échiquier 5 bien joué
lui va avoir comme lundi dans avec là
aussi d'un beffroi d'un point d'écart
alors qu'il progresse un barde des
services internes et dessin avec trois
points d'écart
mais qu'il est bon enfant au pied mais
au caire et ce malgré le plan
moral je fous aussi soudé ça moi j'aime
bien le foot mais quatre échecs parce
que l'on joué sur le fait que cette
tactique
qu'on va interroger fois ci ce qui est
intéressant
ont été réduits de vie d un destin des
minerais
rollmatic n'auront aucun mon père pal
pions dans d'hubert tout ça mais
attention quand la photo à blesmes
pratique à manger avec la ja j'ai
toujours trouvé calais jacques méreau
quart d'heure
ok il ya la pratique quand même endroit
appelé les blanc et roux et
ses promoteurs mouvement grave se croit
du coup elle a pris 125 à cancon pas
l'air de le demi-heure vendre leur
maison que terra east side avant et
il l'a fait pour moi et pas pour toi qui
venus parce que ça veut dire j'ai peur
de ce que ça veut dire
faire
d'un coup là il est vraiment manger
mission pour le coup
si vous lui avec monaco 2 1 à la place
de four 3
jusque dans ce cas-là ça glisse par jour
je me fais dam des 8es première descente
on se fera un peu chiant dans la prise
de salah pour le branchement mais
normand savoir peut-être les actifs
actuels je t'apprendrai blanche
non je ne suis pas fan le père et les
prendre ok donc lie avec de me2 je pense
que je l'aï trop
prise en estimant qu' on est aux normes
mais
c'est le bagne mon registre
on a bien changé depuis la gamine star
juste au passage vous montrer que
d'après
intermédiaire n'est pas possible parce
que faut il reviendrait tout simplement
et ils auraient au passage je croquais
un cheval il serait trésor donc sur foot
français c'est un cas pas le choix ou
reprend et ce cavalier calme bien
voyager à faire des petits aller-retour
à bright ravir en 17 dont qui protège le
pionner certes attaqué deux fois mais il
y avait aussi une pression sur ces 5
et donc on va se rendre compte qu'il va
sacrifier ce pion à marc andrieu moi
j'aime vraiment bien ce qu'il fait trop
ici il a rockets
comment
donc normal en filant vers le le maire
de caraquet il a besoin de moi
ouais il à l'arrière de développement et
pas mal de mer il a il a déjà la colonne
de sfr le visage du roi dame qui est
toujours très dangereux même si
l'appétit pour couvrir
le ripage le fruit sera pas forcément
stable entre 3 et pourra se faire à se
faire embêter peut-être il ya un pion
c'est ça qu'on va menacer le récupérer
quelque 17
x 17 on voit que en termes de
développement on est largement en avance
et et noir et fougères donc évidemment
il a prévu fort étroit pour parer le
clouage mais moi j'aime bien j'ai passé
j'aime assez ce qu'il a fait avec les
noirs y a sacrifié un pont pour gagner
plein de temps de développement alors
maintenant falloir qu'ils trouvent un
implant peut-être actifs pas comment il
va pouvoir se meurt est ce qu'un plan à
ce criminel comme un taureau 8
pour 8 kg cassill d'aller manger sous
bien sûr élan contre l'europe c'est
quoi pourquoi pas un point ce sel mais
quand l'autre mais pas m'en priver
si oui mais je m'en fous eh ben je ne me
lasse pas
entrepris mais peut-être
fou g4 parce que si on force f3 mais ce
n'est pas le cas ça va être il avait une
grosse concession des blancs pour vous
pour bloquer leur fouet si vous leur
donne
peut-être faire ça brûle
les poumons qui évidemment d'efforts on
a le sentiment qu'on a quand même
récupéré au moins le pion en quoi cette
on essaie de garder les daouze en échec
pour les membres et offre de widgets
autour des 8 heures
peut-être synthèse pour au 8 mai même
tour hui trouver 3 et par exemple d'un
mot c'est
un bien beau
mais en fait cela n'entache
développement qui est assez conséquent
mais qui peut quand même vite être
comblés donc vous faire attention ça
marche un peu périmées se déplacerait
pas tout à l'heure et en fait voilà si
sud et blanc arrive vraiment à
stabiliser le noir
et blanc la remplace pleure la part de
croupion plus mais bon
aujourd'hui vite foulée 3 est donc faux
cils
sûrement pourra pêcher les grands lacs
c'est qu'un important de noter c'est que
ça sent le gros à nantes il est
seulement quatorze coups de genoux et
même 13 pour marc andrieu il a déjà crû
de 35 minutes donc les risques de devoir
jouer ces vingt derniers coups quasiment
chansons d'un créneau comme ça ça peut
être bonjour et son adversaire ils n'ont
pas très bien entendus alors que j'ai
quatre bijoux comme je trouve attention
là ça sent pas très bon pour le français
qui jouent exactement la première idée
de touffes
bon est-ce qu'on annonce la défaite de
suite ou pas
c'est naturel ce qui m'a fait rencontrer
3 et 5 oui et même celle là mais bon
[Musique]
rock du couteau ni de faire prendre et
il va faire du dernier set pour se
déclarer et il faudra juste trouver au
monde se fout donc là par contre ils
jouent plutôt clairement pour il se bat
pour l'égalité quoi ça le truc dans
cette position il se bat pour récupérer
son enclos
et effectivement il a deux cibles donc
il a quand même des compensations
clairement
il y avait peut-être un petit peu
souffrir du court
oui oui avez dit simon sagan et à
vouloir manger à perdre et fou ça fait
sens
mais c'est qui permet ce grand roque la
rb score qui est assez intéressant pour
les cordes ce qu'ils réservent à leurs
problèmes de développement d'un seul
coup finalement ils sont sortis bafouent
leur tour victimes le roi sema la bride
et en deux temps trois mouvements ils
ont rattrapé leur retard de
développement
donc ok moi partie intéressante on verra
comment ça évolue peut-être dans le
zénith note
comment vont se faire la deuxième pause
3 minutes wars tu veux arriver là à
faire une petite pause non ce ne tende
apparaissent comme hockey et on va
revenir ensuite et du coup avec
merci d'avancé car c'est un
atout
[Musique]
il
oh
[Musique]
et là on entend dans son cou j'imagine
j'espère en tout cas que vous pouviez
lire sur mes lèvres c'est un petit jeu
sympa
un bon entraînement merci
aux quais du coup je disais je réponde à
la question au passage sur un axiome qui
jouent pas qui va se concentrer sur les
grands prix qui vont commencer en
février mars pour essayer d'arracher un
des deux derniers tickets pour les
candidats et donc là même son sang
français on a quand même quelques
parties sympa notamment ceux d'août à
carson qui suis un petit peu les traces
du championnat du monde entre les pôles
et le norvégien on en était resté à
foule s'y sont à délaisser le numéro un
polonais en pleine réflexion on avait vu
qu'il est fou un kart qui était possible
pour coup et est finalement il a décidé
d'en manger au 26 et là aussi on avait
vu qu'il ya deux options et
magnus a choisi la plus conservatrice en
touchant pas sa structure de plus on l'a
pris avec la tour
on va attendre le retour de stuff qu'il
puisse faire son petit air de mode au
passage
et tours précise donc ici duda il a joué
de l'es4 donc depuis le début on en
parle des enjeux ma position le premier
cahier affaires les percées centrale qui
peut-être prendre un léger ascendant
donc là toutes les conditions sont
réunies puisque son chiot leucate et
bien défendu il ya deux adacore deux
défenseurs puis je vous des quatre
cartes cela ait changé et la intéressant
et l'a repris et que lecavalier
donc ils apprêterait à supprimer ces
cavaliers l'art de la position peut-être
pour mettre une pression sur ces 7
est ici car scène plutôt que de
s'arc-bouter la défense de son client il
avait contre attaqué sur le pion aux
quatre ont rejoint dans le vide
il fatto à la pad est peu encore sur une
chaise comme
l'erythrée a peut-être que je ferai une
un petit gens vers un petit message pour
qu'elle puisse obtenir son épée qui la
suit partout normalement
ça pourrait nous être utile je pense
car à en croire parlait
donc j -c magnus qui rajoute une
troisième couche sur le cuir ou quatre
qui est pour l'instant défendu ce manque
deux fois
au caire ont logiquement je pose duda
décide de ne pas troquer 1,4 pour ses
sets
et bijoux des sacs
donc attaquent à tout en gagnant tant la
tour recul reflète ma part les russes un
coup toute façon elle serait sous le
coup des pièces et nuit donc les risques
et juste de perdre des tempos voix
courriel fouet fait qui fait grise mine
mais il va certainement trouvé une
seconde jeunesse dans la grande
diagonale assez assez assez évident
comme port pour magnus
et or a continué par tous rakat marqué
les tours à cannes tout simplement
défendre notre lancée car ça assez
l'esthétique je trouve comme coup et
sûrement peut-être ensuite venir venir
dans cette cave donc là la tour à l'oral
double rôle
la casquette on fonce eux est défoncée à
la fois donc jamas eh bien ce coup de
mou d'où d'arnaud boeuf ka c'est souple
mais l'expression
tourbe et de a été jouée par magnus
assez joli jeu vous sur le système
tactique la déviation meinl s'il veut
soulager la position forçant des
échanges
caraman cette position on peut
considérer que c'est plutôt les blancs
qui joue pour le gain et magnus pour
essayer de dalles et consolider une
petite nul
d'un pro d2 paraissent
plutôt forcé d'enfants à 4 donc on se
retrouve maintenant à dos avec une
triple attaque sur ce pion donc là on
aurait pu s'attendre à un f3 pour le
défendre mais tout a encore une fois il
choisit un moyen plus astucieux
moi je m'en fous des 4 donc on coupe une
attaque et leur âge on tune qui et on se
retrouve avec un deux attaquants contre
deux défenseurs donc donc c'est au
chievo passage il met le fus de rabat
agdal et met une pression sur les
cavaliers abscisses
et où va le cavalier noir elle c'est une
bonne question posée par saga nesta
est ce qui va plutôt en 17 pour essayer
de se rapatrier sur ces cases là et ce
qu'ils auront à 5
même si à chaque c'est un petit peu
comme les halles est ce qu il ya plus la
case avec 14,8 à un peu dangereux il en
danger il peut aussi revenir moins huit
hommes voient la cen sad vu un passif
mais c'est vrai qu'après il tient tout
moi comment tu passes peux te dire ok je
fais un mur vas-y
pas forcément facile de magnus a dû
subir comme ça
là j'aimerais pas du tout à voir là
dedans dans cette position
l'éblouissement tout le temps
d'améliorer de mettre de la pression de
gravelines tour
donc pression pression sur le champion
du monde qui pourrait être en danger
parce que vous en pensez
mais
amène à jouer cavalier à 5 intéressant
donc là c'est vraiment la caser avec
hadj imagine peut-être qu'ils
n'intéressent
du tour a un qui peut partir pour
prendre le contrôle des deux colonnes
ouverte même si elles sont pas forcément
non plus si intéressante que ça c'est
une tour qui est la sienne ça peut être
dangereux et on a récupéré stouff
refus
et turku stouff
lui verrait en trois minutes
notre ami charcuterie demande son cours
d'espagnol stuff les arrange a repris le
vert
adoptons d'absence du coup j'ai essayé
de décortiquer cette l'évolution de la
position entre quinze années lula et on
voit le joueur polonais moi je trouve
qui met une pression j'aime bien j'aime
bien les blancs
peut-être que 400 voix à celles appelant
comme ça mais
d'habitude manger est faible
c'est ça paraît un petit coup dont je
reviens un peu de jeu quoi est il ya des
dettes pour les blancs
les au passage tout fait ce que tu peut
désactiver le mode lan dont notamment le
mode lan du chat bilan une hormone oui
c'est un peu râlant bas je crois
est ce que tu peux bad aussi au passage
au western duel
d'une pierre deux ep
voilà
c'est tout ce qui fait parler son
autorité naturelle
pareil eterlous depuis un moment ça
commence à devenir un petit peu
beaucoup de place et au mercato donc
ça nous fera des vacances on va pouvoir
se concentrer sur la partie donc je
pense qu'on a quand même bien fait le
tour ici sur 47 duda que des joueurs en
40 minutes censure 24e cours
ok on va voir si doux d'art arrive à
mettre vraiment en danger le champion du
monde ou sicav est saine a empiré a
égalisé donc on va pouvoir continuer le
tour et peut-être se replonger on a une
partie intéressante double file
ou là mais c'était même la partie de
georges pour l'instant dont
c'était un gros bordel avec du golfe qui
s'était montré hyper créatif alors on
revient pour ne rien on était resté vous
notre ami vite et est venu manger le
pion à eux quatre ils ont été là et de
voir fini par jouer le coup qu'on avait
prévu dame ces deux
kalimucho alors que sylvain coke avant
quand gamin ça c'est pas possible c'est
à dire c'est du vol
mettez vos les devants ils vont pas
ensemble on fatigue des glaces comment
on peut faire c'est vrai mais
il a joué comme c'est d'eux dont il
défend en tuant ses trois il a une masse
de prochaine at-il attaqué ils ont
sûrement préparé du tout donc vide sur
dossier de il n'a pas mangé roger 3
il a décidé de vraiment vide qui prend
tous les risques avec les noirs il a été
chargé le pion maintenant ils me
conseillent de son canal centre je
vois parfois menaçant d enfer même fou
quand ce canal et sera plus en crise
et dubaï elle ouvre la ligne ça paraît
naturel il ya le roi des risques au
centre il est mort il a deux faut donc
faut qu'il justifie
qu qu'avant aux chips pizzas des
cabanons mais fatou la c1
c'est une jour et la nuit
donc il a ouvert il a regardé une
première colonne
pour toi se trouve c'est peut-être pas
clair avec des coups spéciaux mais quand
même
quand on
est du coup tout voir a été joué donc
que des coups de feu pour pour dubaï qui
met la pression dans la colonne d'eau il
ya un bel alignement une belle brochette
et du coup maintenant ils décident de
manger roger 3 alors est ce que il y
avait peu de relève
les sacrifices de qualité de croix qui
pourraient tenter on ne s'est pas laissé
comprendre il peut par ok en fait avec
les noirs salaires hyper dangereux se
fouetter phase iii en fait c'est qu'une
fois qu'il faut toujours prompt à
4-5 qui est
en fait il peut pas bouger regardez ce
cas là il peut pas bouger sans quoi y'a
le pion à 5 kits ont baissé d'un ton
bien à tour derrière
ce cavalier il peut pas bougé non plus
parce qu'il ya la colonne qui s'ouvrait
ce serait d'abord triés cette table est
aussi voilà un des fondements du pion et
façon elle ne pourrait pas faire
grand-chose de mieux ailleurs ou peu par
ok vous la tour sert à rien le fou est
bloquée cette tour elle peut même pas
arrêtez pas raciste que la case est
contrôlé moi j'aime cette position gérer
son plein nord ils sont perdants du coup
finalement il va peut-être la seule
solution ce quartier projet 3 pour
résoudre certains problèmes
et jouer aux cartes celles à partir
de nouveau parti à je continue à donner
les noms webb a aussi clairement à la
d'énormes dépréciations pour le pion des
cas précédents alors j'ai 4 ouais j'aime
j'aime beaucoup mais c'est vrai qu'il
est libéré les dégâts c'est cool mais 32
go sur un revêtement des cloisons
programme il roi et les tacles décidé de
casser la chaîne 500 ko et que vous les
nourrissons car je mange mais avant ce
livre vraiment arrêt et présenté des
noirs celui ci l'a libéré les a acquises
il rire demain à la pression sur quatre
ans au plus vite et donc la demande
donc j'y venais courbessac doit aussi
arriver un jour pour aller se trémousser
sur un bon gardien et
[Musique]
je
donne pas cher de la peau des gens
parce que bon c'est ce curieux quatre
tombes c'est toute la boutique qui
tombait le fait de ne pas pouvoir
évoquer de pas voir d'un bris pour
l'euro à ces problématiques
et une jupe aurait pour
ian jones n 1 luke you à troyes où il
arrivera c'est le cadet des soucis des
deux cours d'ailleurs ce qui nous
intéresse c'est la sécurité du roi john
thune plus ce serait camille car d'aller
chercher ce point parce qu'il ya trop de
prolin tour dure la vie peut se détacher
de l'aspect matériel est
passé à sept points
d'accord peu influent ça reste un pion
mais dans une position où laura noir est
complètement à poil et pas nous laisser
devenir alors ils recherchent d'autres
couvertures pour cacher ton mois pour le
mettre au chaud donc la joie que ces
cinq pour défendre les deux pions d'un
coup donc c'est bien c'était le seul
coup il était logique
il me suis quand même ici libère un
petit peu les lycées baddou paf a
continué de manière très logique aussi l
enlever son cavalier qui était attaqué
même s'il n'était pas un bon job pour
l'instant il y avait une pression sur
les banques
et la visite il a joué le courageux
roi et fit ou tour est vite dans tour
eiffel musée pourra lafitte pour ceux
des clous et pourquoi pas
même ça paraissait assez suicidaire mais
tout est fluide mais quand même tu
gardes ton roi dans cet alignement ça
paraît très très très drôle jument
ça paraît compliqué pour
renoir où il défend son pion maintenance
à la double de trouver comment
comment porter l'estocade à priori a pas
de bien pour l'instant mais sa carrière
prometteur
ou à bas
ce qui peut manger
prise devant être président
moi j'en ai président
ravages blanc
bah oui c'est même ça
alors là on a une suggestion et de
l'ordinateur je triche je veux bien
partager l'enlever pour être un pompon
de
très jolis et
comment
ah
non c'est
ce que je viens de voir qu était une
suggestion
à partisans sont là
et donc surprise prise
là il y aurait donc trouver celle qui
est très jolie eu l'idée c'est de dévier
escalier qui défendent pions de cartes
taxi on manque à tours on va pouvoir
manger le fou
normalement contexte parce que parce que
surtout reprend donc quatre jeunes
allemands qui les tours 5
donc après est-ce que l'ordi il a vu un
et j'ai enlevé leur dis donc je sais pas
il a vu 1 bat quelque part ici
ça me paraît pas évident pour arte riche
et du coup ça c'est vraiment la
condition que
j'aime beaucoup du golfe
peut-être qu'il ya là
l'idée si vous formez un ketchup est
non il n'y a pas de potes sagan istar
effectivement l'idée c'est de faire
baisser
et ensuite seulement et vite parce que
ce roi maintenant on peut manger d'appui
la protection
et s'il attend si le roi bien là il ya
la fourchette d'où la culture ce petit
fou des cinq échecs c'est trop serré
c'est complexe mais cette trouvaille
pour du beurre cette idée
parce qu'on sent qu'il ya des thèmes
tactique dans cette position donc il
peut avoir le flair de diriez vous que
je cherche un truc ça peut être une idée
à voir ou à peut-être le réseau bleu
laisse un peu réfléchir
et refaire un petit tour sur facture
nature pas de partie terminée
donc j'ai été mauvaises langues pour
si penguins et bientôt
notre ami faguy
notre ami famille fabriquer ce qui donne
alors on en est et où
on était un cavalier de 4
c'est vrai t'as combien la virtuelle
le projet
pourra centre essaie de faire une
recherche
le rêveur
ses droits et de les jouer maintenant la
95e
raté sur une belle lancée
quatre
ferries ou moins
terrible 6 buts y avait quelqu'un qui
demeurait dans le shanxi en arrière sans
doute d'énormes de grand maître est très
bonne
alors
d'abord pouvait pas laisser m
mais on va revenir un plus fort
alors que
ces trois donc comme j'ai un bon
contrôle un peu l'écart sur two d4 en
l'occurrence b6 c'est logique mais
peut-être remettre son fou dans la gamme
des connards là on va parler de cette
position avec la concession
là bas
c'est vrai sur les bonnes recettes de
tva au monde ce que je pense
pour maître fide il n'y a pas besoin de
normes
il faut il suffit de devenir 2300 même
virtuellement d'air sur les habituels
manque perd des points avant la fin du
mois et du classement ça marche quand
même
que tu as perdu ton titre de maître et
fientes et candidat m
serait bon que ça gangsta te passe
devant fait enfin management un petit
coup
le seul classé que moi d'ailleurs
peut-être
alors pas pourrait peut-être pour
soutenir dans la colonne de créer un
visa ni avec le roi est potentiellement
à avoir des idées de e65 y sont
thématiques aussi dans cette finale de
berlin pour des tactiques créer des
choses food et 8 on voit qui joue
vraiment sur la première rangée notre
ami choquant c'est le joueur de fond de
court on va voir si fade il essaie de
monter au filet pour
installer joseph iii ne peut pas
vraiment dire ça
f3 c'est quoi l'idée
niveau juste améliorer petit à petit
cela positivement ouais on va pas de
soi
bah c'est sûr en fait juste le nom ne
fait rien moi je vais m'améliorer petit
à petit j'ai le temps avec des faux des
[Musique]
capitaux mais la raison la raison
dragani star affiche claude essai de
ranger ses
cépages différents bugs tour est fixée
élevé par la tour eiffel
il aurait dû faire tout à fait dommage
parce que là il n'était pas loin
j'aurais pu tenter ça
pour admettre que j'attende il était
passionné
[Musique]
de
l'unique
[Rires]
joueur américain
prend le bouillon et les cheikhat alors
là il va vous qui avez l'air intéressant
tous ces cavaliers apsys
à priser carrière
bon je ne veux pas juste une voix casse
courageux rajoub a calculé le feu
est ce que ça donnait quelque chose ou
pas je sais pas en tout cas c'est matt à
l'étouffée si on prend pas le pion donc
ya pas le choix vous prend pas les
cheveux
et du coup
bon
c'est intéressant comme moi j'aime bien
ça ça des comptes un peu la position
auront peu de jeunesse à la faveur de
trous noirs noël tu fais quoi
fini les gammes bien qu'il ait
lui aussi effet les vendeurs jouer avec
g4 et affronter quatre
mois ont passé
mais des fois ils
ne
nous croient de 16,5 à nice tu as
surmonté sa
crise
est
peut-être on vit ici alors un giga même
les footballs reposer ici sont en hyper
et de dangereuse compte propre ou wayne
option fabi a préféré garder l'attention
envers il a joué ses quatre
parties g4 qui prend des cases il ya eu
h probante
hockey est intéressant aux îles il va
toujours sa petite pression avec les
blancs whaou
on va voir comment il réagit champions
après je serais pas surpris de voir
habile à gagner celle-là je ne sais pas
j'ai plutôt un bon pressentiment
kg 6 le fauve a reculé où je passe
d'aller là où la
g3 paraît naturel
on a une question est vite y revient
souvent sur les différences hommes
femmes aux échecs
mais du coup je vais te laisser le soin
d'y répondre à mon cher stouff pour
mercy buycott le plaisir est bien
bas des gens déjà qui en moins de deux
heures
de marche aux et après
bah c'est vrai que
pour pertes niveau adéquat de fin on
va dire
moi si fort que les un petit peu
pour
être égaux au niveau rythmique un
terminal
2b et du coût bien moindre
donc
en france
par exemple on mélange de domaine
personnel
non on espère aussi au même niveau
valérie gas d'une personne en france
trois ans qu'on ait des milliers
étaient encore poligny
chacun à la colle à l'image
de mathieu
divertir
et marie se remettre mais elle est en
fait du coup c'est pas énorme du coup
après les pays qui ont pris 10 1 et du
coup c'est pour le niveau pour prier un
peu
après un gain ou deux joueurs qui sont
là mais
je
sais que c'est une situation complexe à
présent dans une situation c'est dur à
trouver une bonne solution
ou alors vraiment on reprendra des
années en arrière changer des choses et
repartir sur des bases plus équilibrée
mais c'est vraiment un sujet complexe en
réalité c'est dur de trouver en moi
parce que les joueuses professionnelles
le problème c'est que si elles ne
peuvent jouer qu'avec les armes a
finalement effectivement peut-être que
leur niveau augmentera parce qu'elle se
trouve à faire une forte adversité dans
l'état actuel des choses parce que de
bain et fiction et aucune raison
qu'elles soient récemment forte jusqu'à
ce moment nombreuses donc ça crée une
compétitivité intérieure mais du coup et
pourrait peut-être trop fait puisque la
meilleure joueuse du monde allez je sais
pas combien de mois et on voyait très
peu de joueuses qui pourrait être
province qu'elles gagneraient moins
d'argent dans l'unité en quoi donc du
coup dans une situation compliquée pour
à la fois maintenir les joueuses pros
bah alors activités mais en même temps
du coup ça leur permet pas de progresser
plus parce qu'elles restent souvent
frère donc c'est un peu un peu compliqué
et sinon elle en est notre premier
résultat du jour effectivement c'est une
bulle irrite décevant on va voir birima
mais
direz qu elle nous l'avait laissé moi
j'aimais beaucoup les blancs toi aussi
d'ailleurs
dans cette position il a choisi de faire
foulée 5 l'échec
d'une royale fuite il a échangé les
larmes sa banque ou quoi
c'est le train pour le courant jet
ski si la gamme un pion de plus
de 5 à
vraiment choisi la suite la moins
ambitieuse
foule trois
cas conduit à des échanges un combat si
g5 et la mezzo requis qui va gagner ce
nom réussir son pari re de jouer g5 g4
dans toutes ses parties
ici c'est simplement pour mettre son
rouge 17es empêcher les planques de
4,3 à cette aiguille à proposer mieux
priori relais j'imagine qu'il ya eu
mieux
c'est bizarre de proposer nuit sinon
avec l'aide des
forces et
morale des
dégâts
gagner ça peut être long baiser
h2o innovation
il n'était vraiment pas en tissu du toit
et qui rit aujourd'hui d'inspirer j
étais sans en fin de compte nous est
aujourd'hui proposé un petit peu c'est
un peu
la leur se
rappelle là où quatre donc demain c'est
la 1ère ronde avant une autre mercredi
en
retour d'un autre duel de russe battant
va peut-être pas aussi chaud pour moi
avant marc andrieu parce qu'ils étaient
mal autant c'est pour cela je veux une
évolution qu'est ce qui sépare les
analystes on reviendra au tournoi
principal ainsi donc on était resté à
quai gk donc les grands axes comme très
vieux
cheikh qui est prend la 3 kg en pro à 3
il a mis cette avance est plutôt qu'en
sais tu
pourquoi pas peut-être qu'il veut
doubler tour du coup sur les colonies je
pense
que c'est encore le 7 mai directement la
pression mais bon hockey
et 3 et 6 du coût carcinologique
tours 5 la pression est doué et où il a
joué pas il a doublé raison entourage d
un hockey ouais un peu fou il a fait
froid ça
ça paraît logique
mais problème c'est qu'ici se passe quoi
sur e4 double
faire attention à colonne des aussi bas
les couloirs blancs
ici très utilement
du coup il a l'air d'avoir quand même un
petit peu clarisse est vrai avec les
blancs malheureusement
hors 4 du g4
ou peut faire d'amendé de promenade
s'est directement m du couloir
admettons que quatre ok je joue je
n'attaque plus d'âme bouge
là faut voir que la reprise n'est pas
possible
à cause du thème du mat du couloir il y
aurait d'un programme en cours et
derrière c'est matt
vrai problème dans la position de marc
andré à
la faiblesse de ses amis tiennent bon
j'ai
donc sa victoire bouger sur une fois ici
donc je ne sais pas où j'ai six
syndicats
mais là il y aura autour de cet objet 4
ok je sais pas 3
il a peut-être récupérer un pion mais
c'est possible que par exemple après
faut être jour une pression sais pas
trop mais
ouais il
pour lui car l'état
dans deux parties dans la nation ils
risquent de subir ces classes
par niveau semblable après la mort elle
est foutue jules c'est vrai nom
de ce parti dans l'embarras les voir en
même temps je viens même kevin et la
pâte requis non plus les risques du
siècle en italie l'appareil est sûre le
tenant du titre jardins de mount forest
par rapport à ben guerdane d'hab on
apprécierait comprenant le monde est uni
c'est pas des masses de choix de joueurs
du même nom et non mais en retrait
devant lui c'est vrai que
les rangs du parti
alors on va revenir
qu'à son ouverture d'armand disait que
c'était contre intuitive à sont fous ces
cas peuvent être un peu étrange donc
rempli et du coup
on dit qu'il a un peu perdu le fil par
ici notre ami prague la réaction foule
si ce n'est pas le coup du siècle
là ce avait quand même là rejouable
encore virtuel mais beaucoup les noirs
il a mangé
en disant je vais récupérer espions les
derrière je mens une bien meilleure
structure
vingtaine d'a340
il découle la vf 4 mai qui se fait des
trous de son champion ils essaient de
défendre ils évoluent pour s'accrocher à
ses pions coûte que coûte
sans que j'aie modéré un
des trois qui est pas le district
tordait quatre saveurs d'antan
b4y double
3,5 tient tout ça me paraît pas si
évident non plus ici de passer pour les
blanches pas comment qu'est ce qui s'est
passé trois mois après l'échec aux
caisses est assez malin pour vous
prendre de
règle à tour un bouchon
ouais intuitivement tutorat des mourants
par l'armée
mais des fois il peut défendre au fait
ouais c'est ça que
j'aime pas trop cuite mort ok
ok ok mais ces droits étaient en jeu
il a joué f3
derrière on voit que
le pion bail et
[Musique]
huggel
a divisé les six qu'il en avait marre
dit il voulait pas faire que subir qu'il
allait finir par la paire de gants avec
une action qui peut rien faire à part
attendre avec des structures non plus sa
structure est vraiment tellement
dégueulasse que c'est compliqué
puisqu'il faut que je me tienne activée
mais
maintenant
le pense oui
attention aux problèmes et à plus de ton
peu
comme on vient à son tour de
chant
pourquoi tu disais du sida
[Musique]
cette finale du bon cette semaine les
jeunes ou les parcs ou
ccc mon sens être que
l'on va faire
conclut
il à lui avoir pris part c'est possible
ici la jouer à 6
j'ai du mal à voir je sais pas trop
il a oublié que sur des rois gérer avec
toujours pour g4 pour défendre contre
cet homme ne s'est pas imposé par la
france et moins jeunes
pas de problème pour le problème blanc
et après c'était la même chose que soi
devient de damous tour contre un peu
plus de chance avec les nerfs de fermer
perpète mais c'est sans espoir à cause
de la structure de pions ou donc d'un 9
6 s est accroché à ses pions
roger khartoum un concept a menacé même
des idées à bon par contre rien kg 5
mais voilà on peut s'en prendre au roi
un petit peu
et d'ardèche catawba voilà il arrive à
induire les changes de dames est donc là
qu'est ce qui se passait circuler par
exemple
torje 3 twh trois têtes il recueille
puisse garder les normes sont tellement
pour m'accrocher comme abandonnés qua
non
c'est un mythe moderne ou courir dans
ces cas là il est
monté jusqu'à 6 6
maintenant peut-être grethen
arriver là nous le roi
on a vu hier à droite pas passer
de concours est non reste qu'un crack et
quimperlé
contre-rapport et c'était
[Musique]
ou pire tu fais ça
oui c'est jamais angers d'échanger mon
prêt
à engager
un de contrat cette majorité tout est le
roi qui est arrivé en f3
note de contrat le temps que le roi s'en
occupe nous elle ne trouva tout mon cher
et pas du tout
si touchant la barre des 50 mais ça
va partir on va voir mais normalement
ici mais c'est plus qu'une affaire de
technique pour une forêt ce qui pourrait
jouer encore une partie décisive où il a
fait des victoires à la fête pourrait
refaire ouais on passe ça m'amènerait à
2 2 contre 1 avec 0 et nos
spectacles et même bien
même bien j'aime bien appuyé la plainte
des missions originales gestion des
idées à l'ouverture
alors du coup on va refaire une petite
soif même sur sur nos amis russes
sur nos amis inversion d'arrêter vous
pouvez rentrer à battre
c'est à dire la tchatche mieux que nous
il comprend mieux que nous on le voyait
plus tard et dans ses cartes cadeaux web
est ok ouais là d'une option
québec entame s'est vite car éric in
situ et sacrifiant h3 je ne pense pas
qu'ils aient à 7 le cahier revenus
hockey alors est ce que
oui donc la cemac a rien qui ne vaille
propose nul à do araripe enhco
est ainsi qu il a dit non
ça c'est beau donc ça c'est bien mais
dahleb l'on n' a pas de raison c'est
bien vous qui joue en fait s'il veut
progresser ouais
donc il a refusé et les changes
est prise ici on va avancer un petit peu
pour voir mon nom des
six catherine plaisir de deux cas c'est
de prendre un peu d ce parce que pour
l'instant il est plutôt restreint
crise prises
il faut qu'il y ait pu sortir sur taper
sur la sueur du cisme points faibles
daba 6 dans l'ensemble les contraintes
avec sur ces quatre
le grippage qui nous amène à quatre
coupures bien il faut prend 2,6
et s'il a joué d'un mal cette carrière
qui
alors qu'est ce qui se passait sur
d'autres os 4 est ce que la dame avant
elle est juste au regard non la laine
case les cavaliers qu'attaquer tour 1 4
il faut absolument ayant ainsi
[Musique]
facilement
du coup du coup la demande d'abbas est
assez bas
et qui forcent à priori c'est simple et
y'a pas d'autres qu'on peut pas bouger
le canadien signe à
l'est de damas est très bien joué en fin
de carrière ces 5
force est donc maintenant ça peut
échanger et récupère son pion
williams en sorte il est encore des
idées
et encore une poussette blanche
et pour restaurer 5 est pas possible
quoi parce que la kz1 contrôler
tout copier je pense que l'annuler s'il
reste le résultat le plus probable mais
un petit plus pour
pour ici penco
de respect à avoir grandi lui ce rapport
dans une position qui a l'air très chaud
points et marc
dubord parce qu'il ya des périodes comme
celle ok bon on va regarde très vite ça
m'a d'ailleurs intéressant possible on
va y avoir du bois c'est la partie du
jour frans
bonhomme aura comme on s'y attendait fou
bessette le petit prophylactique roi
mais un ballet noir y trouve aussi le
rock masse comme moi qui peuvent jamais
à croquer du petit côté à cause du point
g 7 qui enlève
qui avait à lille 4
3 p 8 oui notre
tour détroit est la seule logique aussi
pressé d'aller embêter ici
tour c'est lui tout rejet des
gardes sont sortis en rapport avec les
morts même peut-être va pouvoir
valoriser son écran voilà
c'est pas très conseillé en vapeur vous
commencez à jouer un tour la torah
et vous savez pas quoi faire
vous n'est pas une idée tranchantes
rien de plus simple
le serpent plaisir donc peut-être que
rapport il pourrait la mettre le point
avec les pièces noires
va voir et donc du coup on va écouter on
va aller voir d'autres hamidou baffes
qui fait le beau jeu
dont on ne sait s'il ya eu longtemps à
pareil talent
la librairie google qu'il a pris
effectivement prises et tout reprendre
et 7 il va planter tomber cette est donc
là on voit pas là sur la caméra est trop
petit le temps de jeu dit mais je pense
qu'il a plus beaucoup de temps
et donc tour province est l'idée on va
remontrer peut-être cette fois c'est que
sur cavaliers prend
on la foulée cinq échecs
sinon roi lion le fou là pardon à la
fourchette
voilà on mange du fou dame attaqué
dernièrement au dollar c'est
catastrophique
6 mai le fou devant
le fou il faisait un rôle important ils
défendent m tokyo est donc lié à la dame
donc en fait c'est dire que la tour ici
elle est
bah tabou est donc là avec les normes
afin qu'ils trouvent un coup il n'avait
sûrement pas à lui je pense pour 30 17
donc ça fait très très mal à réaliser ce
court
laps de temps après fear the new mutants
ouais on voit pas bien est ce que vaut
pas d'amadouer la caméra non non
ce n'est pas possible ça lui des mois
ouais ben on voit 00 mal autant et il
reste 20 kw à jouer il n'a pas vu sur
mon tour premier set là son roi qu'un
petit peu aux fraises ça sent la belle
victoire de dubaï quand même sens la
commission après depuis le début on a
avancé on aimait bien les blancs il
s'est montré vraiment ambitieux et
gouvernement j'ai dit qu'il a mangé les
pions
mais il est en train de se retourner
contre lui
merci à tous et
à demain fatou
salut
bonjour
et tous rêvent 6 jouer je crois c'est la
ligne même le seul coup que préconisait
la septième s'y sont essayé de
comprendre pourquoi
alors déjà je pense que l'idée
principale c'est de se faire la case f8
pour le roi sur cfoot bichkek donc ça
lui faire un abri
peut-être cacher ensuite engrangé 7
et du coup on contrôle aussi un peu la
casse et c'est donc à papier 6 dans
l'immédiat
donc elle a peut-être ce qui force du
bafa trouver plus loin
et peut-être que maintenant il menace at
on fait feu de tout bois bush a torpillé
tu as mais où du coup
pour te dire
j'ai toulouse aura tenu louis matte est
bien mais bute à récupérer ton qui ont
même si techniquement tu as encore plein
tourment va
vite et qui ont doublé à quoi
ce compris oui je veux bien qu'on a
parlé hier avec kevin elle
a mis trois décès
alors je crois qu'il rend con non
annonce est pas récente
donc c'est pas si facile pour double
final belle défense de visite puisque là
une sacrée pression apparemment il y
aurait sept minutes encore donc ça va
peut-être tour des cinq puisque la tour
attaquer autant essayer de mettre la
pression où
et comment il dit je pense que bédié qui
les contraint à trouver à chaque fois
d'un seul coup de défense pour s'en
sortir dans très longtemps
et sa tâche s'annonce humainement assez
reculée dans mon année marie claude
killy par nature il en a vendu on voit
maintenant
ça va
mais non
quand même mais bon ils se disent pas
bien en tout cas donc
à voir ça va être un beau ça il note un
peu
sait jamais ça peut sauver aussi un
[Musique]
après version v6 et blanc
c'est bien placé a
fait tatouer ou des oui mais oui des
fois qu'on va voir sa défense n'ont du
coup ça peut aussi parfois il attaque
toujours cherché à créer pas toujours
facile
où
donc avoir
à voir on n'a pas ce que j'entends qu'on
n'a pas dû magnus bientôt vous allez
refaire un petit tour il était quand
même en plus sous pression
magnus limonest ou du coup ya toujours
un petit peu sous pression
quitté de joueur après que lecavalier à
chaque
nation commerçante pour la c1 je n'ai
pas osé
des fois il a dû aussi relevé m wen
pauvres
après y'a toujours tourner en rond qui
pose problème mais au kebab à la décence
oui oui
toi toi et d'un 17e sanction était joué
ouais et
il aurait pu améliorer toujours eu du
tout rêver donc c'était pas forcément
très utile la fedom c3
je pense qu'il faut juste mettre sa dame
sur une case vide mais l'impression aux
championnes garde un oeil sur ces thèmes
roy et il reste dans cette batterie
tantôt à cette arrivée un jour
les plans
y a plus d'espoir
précieux
voir ce serait le jackpot bien sûr
saluer d'un f3
maladroit musique du coutelier par roger
6 peut-être la case e51
pour faire revenir au céreq sa tour pour
remettre la pression sur ce option qu'à
ça va pas une manoeuvre parce que j'ai
dit du golfe doute parce que tôt ou tard
pour lui craint pas grand chose on peut
tourner un petit peu faire de petites
menaces mettre la pression sur carlos
est le laisser mariner dans sa position
passive
dans 24 a été joué
leur batteur de pression on revient
c'est un peu le jeu du chat et de la
souris
et le goût de stouff f5 et dans tous les
parcs à thème bravo
les jeunes voient
[Musique]
donc la prise était impossible
du coup du g3
contrôler set 4-4
et maintenant magnus effet exactement il
n'a pu échanger
[Musique]
merci
aussi au cameroun et les
entreprises à travailler
et oublie aussi le plan des sentiments
qu'ils avaient
effectivement ici car c'est nous on est
là il a joué de clamer vite dans cette
position il a rappelé des saddam ou
qu'ils aient le temps de colmater les
brèches sur 15 broches et mettre la
pression à dans la colonne veut donc un
bon coup je pense qu'un seul cas bien
jeu vers les derniers coups avaient été
très précieux pour réussir ajustement
n'est pas que subir et c'est de créer
des petits problèmes et forcé des
événements je pense qu'il est quand même
plutôt sur la bonne voie il faut un peu
sous pression mais son mauvais foule à
petit à petit je pense qu'il est un
petit peu moins de problèmes que il ya
quelques coups
on est contre le revenu
pourtant nombreux gauche algérien trop
cher c'est une heure une heure
précède peut-être ta connection six fois
[Musique]
hockey qui s'époumonait un support
vers 6 heures
ajoutait banques continuent de sacrifier
un ses gammes ne prend tous les risques
un déni d'albert il laisse sa tour
une menace du tour b 8 dont qui force un
peu austère d'attin beaucoup d'amour et
pas du tout envisagé mais c'est moi
j'aime bien l'idée on va essayer de
creuser
sacrifier la qualité
et donc sur cavaliers prend
dame grand
jeu supposé tour des buteurs à air forcé
des fourches il peut déjà récupéré du
matin et en fait
je sais pas qu'est ce qui l'a privé d'un
salaire très très chaud
il peut même là il peut il peut juste
jouer sur la case blanche le 6
mai son roi peut aussi commencent à se
retrouver pas si bien que ça
disparaît comment
proprement
[Musique]
4,5
mais la saga raison
ici la
main par qui nous distingue de leur
échec
l'approché d'un match 8 ça va du coup il
faut je pense jouer tour des
intermédiaires
[Musique]
mais bon c'est vrai qu'il ya plein de
pièges
il ya plein de pièges
je sais pas ce qu'il a prévu ici parce
qu'il peut faire il a peint une
possibilité il
ya plein de possibilités d'endettement
donc
on va voir à tour des activités qui
capturent la
après à ce qu'on est obligé de manger en
17 matchs
arbitrés quoi du coup non jeudi comme
elle promet 7 et la
jambe et 7 pour les blues
ça
peut changer
si par exemple
il a de la chance si ce n'est pas perdre
je trouve
dit en vrai
ça pourrait être perdante de plein de
façons peut-être qu'à chaque fois il a
un coût qui tire mais
mériterait de gagner pour le blanc 13
vous ce qu'il a cédé fois les échecs
c'est un peu sur un film tu t'en sors
cap a tout prévu donc un petit le site à
la stouff
on va voir il faut pas entendre ça va
donc je minimise je sais bien
je n'ai mise
alors si les parties à se regarder
évoluer
ok ou à faire si tu as peut-être je suis
pas des lois
marc andré allas vous propose
d'ailleurs de très bien se passer donc
j'ai eu 4 comme on avait prévu
la doubler et je veux tamasheq pas pensé
à ce cours
intéressants l'idée c'est qu'il faut
bouger des thèmes comme sa boîte
admettons fils
se terminait
du couloir le mat du couloir
d'un machin coup très intéressant de
pierre
martin st louis a viré kato
l'a jouée ces six
là même dû en h4 regarde leur deuil sur
cette case
mais aussi une défense ici il faut aussi
de jouer parce qu'il faut été attaqués
vont de six cases
et à bercy ce sont pas moins pour les
pour la noire tu commences à te faire
trouer sur cases noires ici
réseaux h3c
la partie fuji au japon allaient
reprendre la plage le fouet trois
amis sûrs en six manches pour 17
c'est la partie très bien juste fou
prend du coup il va abandonner
malheureusement il a mangé
des pâtes riz la manger tour 17 et ce
qui est de la bande ou
et
non mais à bientôt en cours mais
malheureusement c'est terminé un way
d'un premier set pour connaissais tu
peux pas je peux pas à sauver tous fous
on est pareil maintenant
y'a pas de quoi tu peut même rater
il fallait pas partout elle fit
elle s'est complètement terminée quoi
la savait où être dur dur pour marc
ouvrière 2 défaites les clés noires
alors quand vous achetez un bon mal en
pis les parents manquent double tendance
à la baisse est dans une position
intéressante où il avait une partie et
ils
sont plutôt bas
même s'il a peut-être pas encore
officiellement abandonné là c'est
vraiment sans espoir dans les mairies
c'est son esprit n'y a pas de coups ici
ça va juste
rouler ses pages de pub
et que moi en
quelques instants
ne bougez pas y'a tout à l'heure aux
mamans de suite
[Musique]
et
oh
[Musique]
ans
à
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e
on est de retour vous devriez entendre
de nouveau en baisse avec dubaï contre
aviez dit qui est la partie la plus
chaude du moment et du boeuf qui
enchaîne les prises de risques et les
sacrifices
ouais mais aussi ben ouais
mais a pris 1,25 ici à tourcoing
5,84 donc ouais on l'a dit terré vidée à
jouer le bon coup tour d'un échec
intermédiaires
et rouages 2 et 3,5 pour sauver sa
l'abbaye si un nombre de voix me le dire
avait déjà bien avoir un carré doit bien
y avoir quelque chose à priori non après
avoir bien sûr en pratique ça peut
craquer il y avait un premier échec
le royaume des vitres sales gosses parce
que sur royal fuite
il y aurait d'emprunt à chis sa
probabilité d'un laser voilà sur échec
mais pas de quoi vous même tout
simplement ici
nous avons plus
donc un
retour à la partie il est vraiment dit
vite qu'ils savent qu'on
est maintenant d'ouvrir les chirac
comment
comment continuer alors il n y étais moi
mais il verra un pion pour la qualité
quand même et surtout il ya ce roi qui
est très faible
carabine d'échec
on peut pas manger parce qu'il y avait
deux reprises
plaints voix il doit monter alors
qu'elle est là où la missive en d6 il y
a car celle-ci ce matin
si je vous sais si ce n'est pas juste
manger ça rien donc du coup un v6 paraît
obligatoire qui ont essayé de s'enfuir
et ici ce que vous pourrez trouver un
moyen de continuer
à djeddah c'est donc encore 90 ans par
porte mieux garder l'attention maxime
gaillac et donc des besoins dans
l'appareil
c'est l'enfer d'un calcul et c'est un
crack qui est patent de la miller était
juste pour voir s'il y avait un gain il
nous a dit que non on va essayer de
regarder un peu par l'om mais c'est vrai
que ça paraît fou qui est pas chez rien
qui
y passent tellement ce rouennais
dans les courants d'art à
paris en position que l'on peut même
milite pour y gagner la partie oui
[Musique]
enfin tellement plus trop rien ben
harper dise il est
reparti
ouais exactement exactement mais habité
il ya eu ce qu'on vient de moquette est
bien probable
et non
plus on n'a pas du tout envie déjà lieu
d'aspirer il prendrait sur échec donc
assez de nous qui nous faisons peut-être
ma tête
alors là je me fous bessac
maintenant moi je me réinvestisse seul
coup le poulain ne pas se trouver ici
c'est pas compliqué on voit que les
autres coûts pertes directement
la pêche
si ce
nom on a alors va directement avoir
alors craint scènes
de joie discute donc tout à perdre s'ils
nous attaquent a pas réussi à
passer à l'heure d'été ici je vais ce
bon coup danowicz a finalement 47,6
compenser il avait joué à ces pressions
défonce
griller ses trois il a échangé les tours
pour un petit peu soulagé sa position
moi j'ai
2,8 pour colmater les brèches après
avoir fait son travail
est ici bas je crois que finalement duda
il a admis ne pas avoir
trop d'idées en tout cas il va proposer
l'échangé des dames
auquel je vraiment ça me serait que
l'échangé dable procès septembre et
donc au fait qu'un ça n'est pas obligé
de bouvet la dame
s'est vite parce qu'on manque un peu de
matériel ont pâti sinon pour créer des
menaces ce n'est quand même très réduit
les revenus en d3 et vu qu'il y ait eu
cette qualité attaqué pour la i40
anglais pourquoi finalement ce mauvais
fuba car sound
cela n'a pas dérangé la laisser là il va
terminer la partie ici évidemment de
4.6 les propositions de de duda
poserait clarey se retrouver
dans une finale
qui a l'air bien bien égal en cavale et
c'est pourquoi le
matériel est beaucoup trop réduire ces
trois points à trois ont tous passé mes
diplômes qui est pas donné pas de
problème assez complètement nue à ce
niveau et du bourg
bien joué de la part de personnes parce
qu'il était sous pression mais
finalement il n'a pas vraiment souffert
il suivent faire le dos rond et jouer
des bonnes séquences et hébreu ainsi
continuer à gagner après que les blancs
il sera dans un rythme de croisière
plutôt qualitatif
donc ok c'est un bon résultat je pense
pour les deux joueurs nous donnent un
air très dangereux qui est toujours dans
le top
2 jours
et lecture en forme avec et blanc il
faut quand même se passèrent assez
claires
dans les dépenses pour le droit
et donc la prise en main par tous de
grandes et mieux cela on n'a pas de
métal qui nous dit que rapport est bien
alors on en n'était pas ici mais gagne
en france en hockey on voit que ça
commence à tourner en faveur des noirs
parce que les blancs sur leur dernier
coup ils ont clairement manqué de dider
simplement pas réussi la voyez vous ces
fameux
pour ses trois tours des 3c petit
aller-retour
qui sont pas très bon signe il paierait
la pétition ouais mais rapport c'est pas
genre de la maison il a commencé par une
défaite nos rapports
trois coups
on a perdu 20 contre et hodan dans la
première ronde
ça est derrière les magasins aux douanes
soir est hélas elle en passe de gagner
contre caen délice avec les noirs donc
il serait mais directement un flot
b3 intermédiaire mais quoi ça sert de
maison royale s'est tenue de course
quand vous êtes enceinte et briquets
remplacement
pour
créer des sous ça crée des troubles
d'un 3e cas tour c'est tout simplement
un saint et qui charge du contrôle jeu
et en plus à cause du froid et ben
j'aurais plus de coups comme ses trois
plus tard pour pouvoir défendre le plan
c
est à cause de b3 j'aurai plus de cette
fois parce que pareille mahdi d'ensemble
qui ont enlevé trois siècles ont été en
b2 le jour où je joue je double mais
tour la polonaise pourrait toujours
avoir cette fois pour prendre des photos
ces trois parle tomber deux exactement
une fois de les mettre en marche en
comité et j'ai du mal à défendre le plus
fort c'est le regard des gens à
compiègne les plombs c'est
très compliqué aurait donc il à double
tour le gic et où charlotte non plus si
on leur répond qu'il a initiés hâtive du
tournage et 3 il va chercher du contre
je à l'endroit même c'est que c'est son
devoir a calé sous pression donc pas
sans qu'un petit contresens la danse est
reparti de grandes ailes lui s'en fout
a3t jouer ils créent des réseaux
il va dire mon g77 fait plaisir
évidemment c'est pas possible parce que
la dame qui rentreraient romatet
et h4h 4 un peu en aveu de faiblesse on
ne sait pas quoi faire mouais bizar dame
bekhadda être préparés potentiel minéral
à cette idée
à 5 pour ses trois
tours c3 et
jockeys donc tout procès 3 toujours
impossible
et là il a été brûlé au g7
s'avère un peu suicidaire n'a trouvé à
la tactique mais
mes pauvres en temps ça semble pas moi
sur un coup comme comme tour des trois
espaces et quoi on soit duclos arrière
en formule est dit toi
si ça marche
bon j'ai avalé ayad improbable ja oui
oui moi je voulais faire bonne mesure et
sec garde 0.6 au lit pour qu'on se
gamelle quand ces deux dames à chaque
magasin programme des hespérides
apprendre à penser qu'elle va les
prendre en main lui faire le job le jogo
bonito ce touch l'euro goni tout le jogo
bonito
francophonie tom meighan ça ne marche
pas
mais bon le simple dames trois dames par
contre faisait le taf du coup
du coup la mangions g7
il a les doigts joue et gagne c'est
facile facile à paris avec un seul gain
il a trouvé un rapport
à l'idée à ce dernier flash mais se bat
sur cases noires mais dû commencer il
faut sécuriser la casse ces trois l'air
ou ac
les joueurs se serrent la main et
l'avant les grandes et plus et donc le
bouc ou qui est assez joli nom qui doit
laisser ma place à sade avec sa tour
mais peut pas les importe où il faut
qu'il aille en h3 pour empêcher la tour
blanche de revenir car son table de fond
c est en fait lorsqu'on compte que les
tours ne peuvent plus défendre
du coup il a tenté d'amener un
pourri si le défi est là notre amour est
cher rapport qui a ou plus avec panache
par le souffre ouais répond tout achat
magnifique un peu dans les têtes
si on mange la dame yvette du couloir
vous voir vous l'avait annoncé en
préambule que le b3 et r
d'affaiblissement et finalement tous ces
problèmes derrière tous les réseaux de
maths à découle de ceux de squid sait
trop sur cases noires
et du coup bahreïn n'a pas le choix
sinon je la donne c'est le matin repas
qui suit donc il a quand même tenté tout
rejet et après tout reprocher tout
simplement le projet d'un de ses trois
c'est la partie grande russe a rendu les
armes donc superbe victoire de rapports
avec les pièces d'or on 31 coups ouais
même passer maintenant à voir qui nous
régale
très bon style de jamhour cours jolie
finition moi vraiment c'est un joueur
qui joue potentiellement pour les deux
résultats avec les rangs pour les trois
résultats avec les deux couleurs petit
agneau ou
alors parce que pourquoi d'avoir un go
way
[Musique]
ok je commence à tourner un peu saccadée
alors sip godon ou la super coq y serait
gagnant blanc qu'est ce qui s'est passé
il ya en tout cas l'impression qui
domine sur l'échiquier il est vraiment
en retard et se tient
sur le bord de l'échiquier mais
l'impression même souvent langage
corporel carrière alors qu'à ce qui
s'est passé
les territoires une position bourdon
s'assembler petite poucette blanche
n'est pas à rien de dramatique surtout
pour un défenseur comme
la tension on tient là je pense qu'il
faut que tu les as well as la piccola
mais moi j'attends très bonne
la connexion se laisse faire des pistes
manic
en attendant du coup donc on voit qu on
était resté paris sinon qu'est cette
batterie qui pouvait créer des petites m
carrick inc elles sont 7,1 des meilleurs
défenseurs du circuit à part ils
implosent et la jouer gilles 6 mai la
masse est logique et tour décentralise
extrêmement naturelle à 4 consolidé est
de jouer à trois pour activer sa tour
donc jusqu'au la serva pour le ministre
la défense après qu'il a dû se tromper
alors on verra ce qu'il a gaffé dames
trois dames e3 on attaque le pion à
cheese ou créer des petites m2 vis-à-vis
imaginons que carrier à kinshasa moi
j'essaie pour notre champion c'est le
drame il ya cavalier e 6 échecs qu'ils
aillent la donne
donc
ils avaient dame g5
mais le problème c'est que la f4
septembre elle se retrouve un petit peu
à l'étroit ici où son petit à petit ça
tourne quand même pas forcément très
bien pour la noire
qu'avait relief trois dames une seule
case en g3
et g5
ou à des gens qui souffrent et aurait à
voir si c'est le cas le 5 il force les
changes de dames dans le protour cran et
je crois que c'est le gars qui arrive
hélas hélas bien comme elle l'a oublié
son four où il a calculé qu'il a joué
tout revient donc là on voit qu'il me
fouquet attaqué
deux fois et a défendu une fois
way la donne est cavalière pour
alimenter les données sont fournies coup
en disant qu'il allait à 7 contre
j'imagine avec son option a ou b 2 avant
la gloire passée mais il a eu du mal
calculé alan qui est prôné cette merci
cavaliers pro tour à tour pro d2
c'est comme ça nous allons salaire du
joueur espions et largan fort
alors comment réfute
c'est la forme c'est un art show
la suva foulée 3 3 pour un
fou de 3 à trois courant points
à 2 tours en est à deux points
elle a donc une idée c'était tout ratera
pour menacer de manger est tournée a
donc la gâteau de riz aux âges d'or
la lettre des deux questions
la refais pouvez vous en parle
c'est bien la composition peuvent
voir la vie
en rose pour 7,3 tour ces trois ici à
trop attendre 1
1 3
et après comment je crois je leur poule
b 3-1 dès dimanche et la ramener la
touriste hien
c'est très osé de la part de karachi ça
paraît complexe après le jeu lancé c'est
avec ces deux tournois secondaires
elles sont dérangeantes aux menaces du
trou béant russie pour aller tout je
vais passer mon tour
de récupérer la pièce comme ça
parce que cammas est cool de la cour et
ses pingouins continuer à bien vous
comprenez mieux
vraiment en danger en vie dans cette
partie en meneuse retrait dans une
finale comme ça pour essayer de faire
nul avec les nôtres
voir revenir en arrière
mais un retour aux deux il a joué tour
de vessy ping coe
ur de et sera incroyable assure un soin
de jouer j'imagine orient doit revenir
il atteint le monde
tous ces quatre murs exxon risque pardon
mais après
après à deux et que le voir ce qu'est
un fou sekkat à quel moment une visite a
lieu
ici la food & 3 à 3 ou 4 degrés moindres
à deux points à 2 est maintenue même
même une pression énorme de pour hors
jeu au départ
et au
signal ne purent devant le roi
intermédiaires et du reprend à 1
j'entends que montpellier répond le roi
et son évolution sur des fronts dieu
totalement à
371.3 oui le
foot est rond à trois fous là a de
hockey ou trois sets assez intéressant
ce que tu proposes
droit bouge là par exemple 3 2 tout en
deux et donc ton g3
leroy plat mme leroy coupé fait que la
menace pour saisissement l'amour oui
ça n'a pas été vu et ce qu'il y a
plusieurs engagements des
merlus est empruntée ces moments
difficiles en bresse et dans ses bonnes
idées allant jusqu'à 3 way ça mais leur
force et à trois fossés cas tout est
fort sinon à deux boules charge de
contre-jour bateau est pas un choix de s
efforcer sav leurs biens ça va les
revoir si ce qu'il a fait et si bien qu
gagner aussi
tours 2
donc tous vos deux à trois priori
non abordés dans good à dix tours de
pense que muller /
a2 à
a3 joué par karina keane
qui s'organise dans la boue un calcul
très bien car yankees qu'est-ce qu'il a
raté
le roi est nu et tous les droits aucun
goût à rien ben je voulais voir ces gars
la preuve c'est que maintenant il a
sécurisé en fait est la première et la
deuxième rangée et genre un coup comme
tour ici pour mener à son tour des
élections aura juste je pense un joueur
rêve de mbia jamais de tourbe est ce
qu'on montre autre chose mais on fait un
rêve de croiser un enfant parce que
c'est pas mal d avec robert avec échec
est victime en a mais la cour a
donc là ça pour ça fait effectivement
avec une dame reste coi et après c'est
vraiment nul c'est dommage du coup à la
place de sa course 3 est venue il ya eu
échec du fait que cela me fait tomber 1
ouais donc celle à partir toi maintenant
20 cariatides
ils sont plus foncée les pompiers mais
tos maddy
d'ailleurs
je pense que c'est foutu en fait comme
en droit
de militer dans trois à baba retourner
voir le roi visiteurs en attendant de
le dénouement peut-être de cette partie
qui serait quand même une belle perte
des cip échos m sila ya peut-être un
cadeau de serrières vannes jusqu'à une
trêve et son cours voix sur la caméra
qu'est-ce qui on sait garder la santé
c'est quand même très surprenant de la
part de caraquet d'être entrer là-dedans
meilleur venir va y avoir double puisque
de bois qu'il va chercher la victoire
avec son jeu créatif ou là j'ai
l'impression qu'il s'est retourné contre
eux vit peut-être
vous avez dit oulala ça pouvait tourner
on a été là donc il a joué à voir aussi
ce que si nous il ya des maths
il à faire des chèques roanne 6
est à refaire un échec qu'à la logique
c'est chaud cette position assure
rouages et min rager 6 pardon ya fouet
vite nécessaire dont encore que
donc ce n'est pas cru mais non c'est
tout reprendre ses surnoms magnum chez
des mineurs c'est la fatigue j'ai pas vu
que les banques double attaque donc bye
bye bernado donc royal soit forcée
pour rester au contact
ils attaquent à ce roi il faut aussi et
là il a ajoué f3 à doolow est d'après
leur dis ça perd complètement
il fallait se contenter de la nulle part
a maintenant tu as tout qu'un seul moyen
de faire nul c'est dans cet échec
on peut pas prendre s'y habitue mans
s'est passé à la descente
dames 6 le même match car on a fait le
tour belgique qui exercent un moment
donné un petit tour de manège gratuits
donc dame saint vite c'est dire que le
roi doit revenir et donc on peut répéter
les coups ce qu'on vient d'une position
un peu comme ça donc ils avaient se
permettent encore mais apte ou pas
puisque pour le gain de la partie et on
paye il a joué f3
il ya du mal calculé après c'est
tellement complexe ou quatre ans pour
défendre sa tour
pour prendre vite 34 f provokat échec
et a pris et que le roi
est en fait maintenant seront à blanc
sylvie qui est très en danger plus trop
d'échecs une dalle à 8 une amie m'a
invité chez croix 3
adam eve 3 mais leroy hill valley un
guide
et laurenti venant d'un le droit c'est
du buzz qui leur donne soudainement plus
d'échec c'est fini tu donnes des
estivales à ouvrir ce matin aux menaces
mathon de coûts
enfin un peu plus trois coups mais à ce
mode de para tour m c'est incroyable ce
retournement de situation
la journée fut 6 ou 6 6
le passé ouais merci à toi mon
fils
nous égare sans vouloir la montre et
justin c'est ma
place
défendre avec ceux comme ça
mais il ya le mâle g4
pour menacer maladroite dans brumath par
derrière
leur devoir qui est créatif ça s'est
retourné contre lui il aurait dû prendre
le père pète alors superbe défense de
vie du temps quand même
à la qui aurait misé sur lui ayissi avec
son
département où il n'a jamais été
vraiment complètement perdre et il a
réussi à trouver tous les sales coups de
défense
est il malgré tout la créativité do
bumba
là on voit la caméra unis sylvie cette
voie fin de vie d'amour et attraits fait
réaliser qu'il s'est planté et là il va
être un peu un peu dégoûté
ça va pas mal de parties décidé encore
une mi-temps avec les noirs après
rapporte
dans la peinture est aussi semaine
autant que des maladies malignes espaces
et ziegler et de beauf qui va perdre
nature à nantes
et la partie de thermal qui est où on
n'a pas trouvé deux cas l'armée
prétend reste le parti
est double pour libreoffice rigueur il
était petit alors juste pour revenir sur
un aller retour aidé dans sa classe
finalement vous exactement ce qu'on a
appris à dire tour g4
sachant que la finale de moyens
facilement pour les blancs
ok il est c'est un petit peu quand même
degrés des petits problèmes et meurant
et couper quand même et là par contre ne
remplit pas pouvoir revenir
tranquillement
c'est ce qui se passe
sacrifions
votre science endettement l'agenda
et son départ est en attente a
retrouvé de l'activité
bon il faut pas
les pions one paix rue lafond il est
donc
intéressant alice ne s'amusait pas
lutter prend 2,4 puis remise en jeu les
3h
4-3-3 ou de défendre toujours
encouragé sus
pour éviter que les blancs prennent
l'option sur échec par derrière à 3
force laprise battement et
il a cette finale sur un échange qui
perdront
pourquoi ces
gens moins 2,4 contre 2,2 côté se voit
là c'est vrai tout va facilement bloqué
lui et notre quatre coups gagnants
on pourra jouer des coups mais
honnêtement c'est assez facile
du coup on ne regarde leur tour pour
essayer d'avoir une petite chance
pratique
mais a malheureusement pour ryan honda
je pensais qu'ils auraient déjà perdu à
ce stade de notre monde il s'agit donc
d'un jour la firme ces derniers temps la
victime est un des cadres rouges weng
cours des deux trois fois elle aurait
coupé un leroy le
j'ai perdu
mon petit clan
genevois 59 sauf pour que
l'argent tombe bien honorer ses peurs
d'après toi
moindre qu'en france un président pris
les seuls à chaque fois à québec lafare
était de se tromper de plomb
allez-vous ses débuts je crois que
donner on voit
la c-zéro et on va voir double à
double qui devrait peut-être faire un
échec ou abandonnés voyais a perdu trois
échecs
le gag c'est la partie si ce qu'on avait
prévu
j'ai
donc aux menaces bat
du coup il peut échanger les dames les
problèmes c'est que maintenant la fina
lattois évidemment beaucoup plus forte
que le focus
ya une pions en activité du rafale est
évidemment élémentaire cette finale on
ramasse tous les pions
donc changer les termes ne sauvera pas
avatar de rage l'échéance il un échec
aurait 7 va sûrement faire un échec s'il
abandonne par google à ce mois ci de
faire face des chèques et après il reste
la partie de de spgo pourquoi les voir
classé le dernier coup de genre ou
plutôt je passe aussi bonne qu ils
arriveront en d2 voilà ouais wild en 2
minutes au tournant peut-être a cité
d'abord à l'abandon en direct de
deux doubles of
voilà raté 2 et sur damas échec moi je
pense que tout cas il
peut prendre peut mettre la dame devant
ils rêvent de roigt céret à lui ai fait
mal et ça il a serré la manche pour
eelv à s'amasser abordons du golf
et du coup vie dit mehdi teale en est à
deux victoires nom de lady reading
la visite vie dit il avait gagné la
première ronde
pourquoi il prend la tête du tournoi
france mais il n'a pas perdu il ya un
vide qui prend à 4 2 me sur 3
il ya il a fait nul contre caruana et le
premier jour il a battu il a battu
champions donc c'est ça ok
ok donc
gens comme un gamin il y est à venir
ouais c'est clair et très demandés le
tournoi de bien et du coup tout et qu'on
retourne sur
la soirée s'est bien qu'hors voir
comment ça se termine ici ping qu est-ce
qu il ait deux jours pour atteindre le
40e revient un peu en arrière blanc
n'était vraiment pas ici voilà à saissac
scandale et ramos et les roues à f2 ils
essaient de 3 1 points contre eux avec
sa tour abc illusoire a priori
ces quatre îles rabat le roi
à la rescousse ap tour g iii
a vu trois séances arbres en france on
s'étonnera sqy ouest
bizarre leur roi série 26 lequel vous
continuez avec ses 3 et de dire comment
tu fais comment tu te des blocs encore
les petits points de pratiquants
voilà
sept tours en piqué pas si facile en
pratique trouve là un fortune à
réfléchir encore puisque tout ce qui
arrive c'est pousser ses pions au fait
tu es fou d 1,5 ou alors lui rapporte
entre -3 et donne
à gagner sa tranquille en foot et rugby
1 pour prendre 2 2 3 2 ici je prends là
maintenant à 30,1 et jeter empêche que
la série alix nous montrer ruitz série
que dans
les mémoires comme ça le thème aero x et
ça quand on voit les pièces défende mes
parents
chrétiens d'entre eux au but en fait on
passa dollars
donc ça marche du coup c'est pas si
facile si on peux pas te la jouer quoi
il a pas nous y réfléchissons 40e et
super quoi donc dernier coup avant le
rajout
sfwa c'est assez froid et des repères je
vois parfois en d1 heureux
pour faire quoi après
c'est de faire ça
bon admettons au pire tu peux faire
juste pour être une fois que le roi ici
tu as joué le cinquième ou aux 4
bon journal de voyage à vélo
c'est ce que je fous aux tâches
défendent les deux je me lasse pourquoi
on a deux par appareil ce que je peux
dire que a tendance à problème
est la proie de ces musiques ça va finir
par gagner du coup je sais
l'euro s'est enfin
trouvée oui parce qu'il va trouver un
moyen âge c'est parce qu'il a raté car
yakine c'est quand même dingue la seule
moment
il y avait tellement mal qu'il abordait
ce pari c'est pas foutu sa position is
enough non c'est que là on a vu d'autres
incarnent bien
quand tu perds ce n'est pas si facile de
manger ses six puisque tu
[Musique]
ne parles pas de fonction quoi il a une
apparence avait largement
piratés
licencier plusieurs façons
trop loin
ok
qu'est ce qu'il nous reste donc bah il
nous reste sa vie pendant des années
voire depuis longtemps donc on va y
aller
faby fabia qu'est ce que ça donne les os
ont été
assez moyens de secours
ont été pareillement ici
champions qui venaient d'attaquer le
faut donc logiquement reculé
prise de la colonne h
ces cartes qui a été jouée
bon contrôle un peu plus de gaz
peut-être ça sera un cadre de santo un
cavalier
qu'elle et qui revient du coup
là soit tu veux mettre permanent des
cartes assez logique alors que pions que
puis en blanc et argent c quatre et un
front en d4 envoyer des e mails et des
cartes est pour ça que les blancs sont
aussi vous et loire le permet d'étaler
dans cette peinture de la salle au bout
je fous
17 et qu'au final evo 3d ronald noir
pour contrôler la classe d'écart
c'a été libérés ces musiciens qui
étaient quittées à la défense
food et 211 est parti c'est vraiment des
manoeuvres où nagent dans ses
dépositions trailer aux marrons on
tourne en rond mais c'est petit à petit
de créer des brèches et de faire craquer
à marsa
ben
ali continue son plan fils prises
regard des changes on se retrouve avec
des voûtes couleur opposée c'est quand
même important de le noter a mais
attention parce qu'il ya aussi une
une entrée pour les gorges mais le tout
a joué toutefois cessé selon qui six
d'entre elles c'est exactement et au
final
c'est un art d'années mais qui vit sa
rue comme toujours on n'a pas envie de
manger évidemment parce que là ça un
centre très puissant
il a joué cinq
engagements fixés
beef un petit trou là à voir ses potes
exploitables
tour d un
roi bouge maintenant il est temps de
faire peut-être revenir sept tours en
jeu
3 g iii s'est montré très longtemps
comme partir moi je laissais voilà
kbc est bonne on s'intéresse à cette
casse donc c'est pas mal
fauvez certes qui avec cinq échecs ou
âgées de 6
et donc là il s'y voyait déjà faire de
leur famille mais a priori c'est pas
trop le genre de la maison il va tenter
peut-être des choses il a répété pour
arriver au 40e et maintenant il a chargé
bonjour toi
ou les sens qu'il va nous faire un petit
marathon monde de trani caruana pour
nous faire plaisir
dans une position
arie f6 de jouer
là on voit bien trop directe
des stylistes ont choisi l'option 1 puis
il ya échange de ces essences de nulle
part on vous rappelle aussi que on
n'avait pas vu de leur début en demi
finale les points doublés des trois
reprises a rendu moins avancée crée
vraiment
un peu passé alors que si les blancs
j'ai vraiment de côté j'ai une majorité
de quatre et même un provoque pas de
susciter de contrats échangés et là
j'aurais de contraindre bien évidemment
les portos difficile à avancer
à mettre en avant oui puisqu'on imagine
norme qui est une pièce voilà donc ça
n'a pas d'importance juste pour montrer
que sur le cube ont pu faire des coups
d'attentats juste pour montrer qu'en
fait les noix ils doivent jamais forcer
un pion parce que quand ils font ça et
l'âme en ce moment vous a donné la
possibilité que les blancs d'un juste à
attendre
et du coup on peut pas soyez à la salle
et du coup le 3 contre 2 c'est juste un
doublon en fait mais là c'est la même
chose
contré avec un double au donc s'imposer
pleinement il arrive jamais à se faire
appeler au passé avec leurs trois contes
de
alors que les blancs près de là à gagner
la partie on en est quand même très très
très loin mais c'est son ami avantage et
c'est là dessus que caruana joue mais
c'est vraiment du très long terme et est
donc on n'est pas sorti de l'auberge
réponse est parti à mon avis ou à
londres
alors qu'ailleurs on a vu qu il sait
bien qu à jouer le plan reste outre
wattré lancé trois rois des bruits forcé
en fait cette fois et maintenant le roi
vous via une blue coat et le shipping co
il agira effectivement parfait voilà
conversion technique en finale de ce
trophée qui est à la hauteur de selle
discipline corps
look qui fait d'abord car ya jim du coup
j'ai tout fait aux cariatides
bas sûrement perdre d'ici une petite
dizaine de courts bon carte comme ça
contre 1 1 plus jeunes joueurs de son
pays
un petit coup au moral quand même pour
karim
après je pense qu'il faut que sur les
candidats mais bon
pas très bon signe a
fait son retour de sur la drague
pasta pas frise le souffle l'impression
que ça frise
je ne tente ont pu utiliser c'est
bizarre tu vas être de tête pendant si
longtemps mais mais toujours
avec
tata free
[Musique]
statue de cire
a
fait baisser cela la bc saint gall en
france prise prises seront vegas pour
mes trois mouvements ouais genou ne l'a
pas de prague on a tenté cette caméra
n'est pas là du coup
le point devrait tomber aussi pour bones
forrest
annonçaient depuis un moment en ce
moment deux heures que c'est une année
sans espoir même si
ça sera suffisant
problème c'est que ce roi est
complètement de mineur par son homologue
du coup
non mais db6 kiwi pour b3 rentes ou
gagnent autant petrov et si le roi être
l'apparition défense serait
peut-être de bonnes chances de noël en
fait le fait que ce roi soit hors jeu en
finale il fait partie des pièces
vraiment qu'il a participé à l'action et
beaucoup joué qu'un à roanne moi et ça
fait la différence
des 6000 et l'avancé prise prise comme
le disent tout sur tourbe et 4 pour
essayer d'arrêter la tour b 3 et du coup
de pions finatawa
3 - vraiment courir en effet la traîne
en longueur et
donc j'ai tout recommencé 2 et là un
seul coup qui lui arrive mais c'est
évident il va le jouer un set en quatre
ans va se mettre derrière le pion
français doit être déjoués
vois la tour b 3
il ya peut-être une émotion pure une
fois mais la bande ou devrait pas tarder
non plus donc on devrait avoir bientôt
les abandons de karuïa kiné prague et
nous restera donc à roanne ashland
ce que je vous rappelle que dans le
challenger malheureusement marc andrieux
a s'est inclinée
avec le noir partie compliquée
ah ben voilà on est sûr que la caméra de
pra loup a peut-être laisse un petit peu
et à
voir ce qui se passe
ici il a perdu dix
noms wes parmi ces partis avaient fini
roubaix 3 et les barres 17,1 sur c4 c4
rouge je pense qu'on va pas se casser la
tête à tomber ça
parce que ça serait un peu dangereux de
laisser le pied dehors mais il ya
peut-être sûrement vrai mais y est mal
tourner ce sont des échecs mais juste
par principe n'a pas besoin de rentrer
là dedans
il suffit juste de bouger notre tour ici
n'importe où
dans la colonne il voit la dame avec la
partie sera combien dans la partie nord
il a mis sa tour et un tranquillement
mais c est maintenant maman 300 voire un
caméra
en face mais aussi plus filmée à la
façon méritée les sables il a joué 7 3
il va rebondir supprimés message
supprimé première première opération le
coup sûr qu'ils étaient là qui viennent
au boom en vain le coup de grâce arie ou
bien sarrias où la tension à seynod qui
part parce que c'est pas une forteresse
à kevin attention
ce qui se fait est qu'avec trois dames
en trois tours 6e pas sûr donc que
war 2 6 et 2 et malheureusement pour ce
tour à tour gérer qui va faire très mal
leurs voix quand la caméra
à camarda
on ne
savait pas de matelas je me pose qu'elle
défilait bien ce qui se passe dans la
tête de preah khan heures
tu arrives pour pour le finish on a déjà
vu pas mal de partir des 6 et votre vie
des deux cahiers qu'elle raconte
redoublent après une partie homérique
rapport qu aux 6000 points avec les
noirs contre eux dans des lieux
et là où va donc avoir bonne forest qui
doit remporter sa deuxième victoire
en battant paris lambda qui avait été
solide jusque-là
il a joué trois des quatre ici et d'eau
qu'on attend l'abandon
ou le c2 pour moi quelqu'un me rappelle
je vais changer on va retourner un peu à
ces deux
tableaux oui parce qu'il est comme
ça
on va directement à aller sur moi sur
carrière qui n'ont ensuite
j'ai l'impression que c'est tout les
cadrages c'est ce qui commence à
souffrir
ah oui la russie
espère
qu'il est vraiment extrêmement rapide là